Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Today has been a wild day.
I'm already so tired, as you guys can see.
It's been a mentally exhausting day today.
Because I had to do a lot of work before the stream started.
There's another one, yes, another one, yes!
but i always love streaming for you guys because it helps me
recharge all my energy up i think i just woke up i woke up
um i don't know i woke up really tired today i think i slept
too much uh i passed i was so tired yesterday because i
didn't sleep that much so i went to bed early um early
yesterday and i think i slept i slept more than 10 hours i
slept more than 10 hours and i woke up and i was still
fucking exhausted i'm pretty sure i like woke up in the
middle of my REM cycle i get it REM so so I'm like mentally
tired right now only because I think I I just woke up um I
woke up in the middle of my REM cycle um so I slept too much
and I woke up in the middle of it um and so and then uh
today today uh I bumped into my neighbors for the very well
not for the first time like We passed each other by.
But coincidentally, I had to grab my food in the lobby
because the Uber driver did not want to do the intercom for
some fucking reason.
So I had to go downstairs to...
I had to go downstairs to pick it up.
And then when I went to the elevator, to go back to my
apartment, one of my neighbors was in that elevator already.
So it was just me and him.
And then I didn't recognize him.
Like, I don't recognize faces very easily unless I see them,
like unless I put a name to it.
So, like, obviously I didn't realize that was, like, my
neighbor.
And so I went to the elevator and then the neighbor turned
to me, looked at me and was like, hey, you're our neighbor.
like oh okay i was like oh yeah i get a hey and he was like
yeah we live next door to you and i was like oh oh hey and
he was like are you a streamer why don't the elevator why
took tune out for you he'll ask me so many questions um
because we live in the high floor and i'm just like oh my
god i can't believe it we i there's so many floors and it
had to be my neighbor my neighbor that was at that exact
time and then and he was like are you a streamer or like a
content creator or something and i was just like like i was
sunlocked by the way i no i just thought i was like oh fuck
i'm at the move i so so he was like so i was stunned locked
and then i i said sort of i was like You guys are gonna be
like, what the fuck do you mean, sort of?
Because I didn't want to give too much information.
Guys, I don't know if you can hear this conversation I'm
having with you guys right now.
The fuck you mean, sort of, Doki.
Because I'm trying not to give too much information.
Like, I'm trying to be vague on purpose.
And I was like, I don't, I was sunlocked.
Like, he asked me if I was a streamer.
I was like, I...
I'm gonna tell you right now, you gave too much information.
Petra said, thank you in the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
And so he was like, oh yeah, what do you stream?
What videos games do you, like he knows I was playing, I'm
playing, I'm streaming video games, I'm hearing guys, yes,
cause like he heard, he hears me like shouting about gaming
terms or whatever.
So, So he was just like, yeah, are you streaming like video
games?
Like, what games are you, do you focus on?
Like, what, the elevator, why was too long?
I don't know.
It went straight to our floor.
That's all I'm like, but it felt like I was in that elevator
for like 10 minutes.
He was able to ask too many questions.
So he was just like, yeah, like, what kind of gaming games
do you play?
Like, what are you focused?
Like, are you like, what, like, do you play like action?
shooters and I was just like the variety I'm a variety I
play variety and then elevator opens I was like oh bye I'm
just like oh variety well that's our floor
I'm a variety gamer like it doesn't give you anything like I
was I was trying to be vague on purpose guys i didn't want
to i don't want to give any details about what i stream or
what i play like i go and now i'm thinking fuck okay like do
i move like at that point and then i was i was actually like
in the middle of also this is why i was really tired because
i was in the middle of a long work call with my manager
because i might have been like dodging responsibilities the
last couple of days.
So then my manager's like, today, and she was like, Doki, we
have to get into this meeting to get work done.
This is, it's starting to get to the point where it's more
important than streaming.
You don't want me to cancel your stream.
I was like, okay, okay, okay, I didn't go.
And so, um, so I was also mentally exhausted because it was
just like, it was like, but it was on me because I sort of
like dodged responsibilities for the last two to three days
because I was like then sleep streaming then sleep and then
he would be like ducky when are we gonna get a call yeah
we're done and i'm like oh meantime you know streaming like
five ten minutes i was like i i just woke up and he'd be
like all right well well we'll do uh we'll get we'll have a
briefing tomorrow and i'll be like okay and then he'll wake
up because my manager's european so like that's sometimes to
my advantage because i can be like i'm i'm oh sorry i was
sleeping I'm sleeping so I couldn't I couldn't catch you
there on time And he's like no, we can't do this again We
can't do this rodeo again This loop of me you being asleep
and then going to stream We can't keep doing we have that's
why I'm also tired Because it was just a lot of stuff to go
overhead A lot of stuff to go over And he was like, here's
this, and then here's that, and then here's that.
All right, next topic, next topic.
I'm like, and then he's like, here's your font.
We could have done half of this yesterday or the day before.
I'm like, you did this yourself.
I'm like, I'm so tired.
Kuka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dirty responsibilities, neighbors, like a true, introvert
gamer thank you with a super chat thank you thank you and
he's like you know this is your fault i was like it's not my
fault it's past toky's fault i'm the consequences of her
actions i many thank you in the super chat thank you thank
you saying sort of to that question makes it sound like i'm
pretty sure with me yelling my like like if he hears me um
sometimes from outside i'm pretty sure he knows that it's
gaming depending on the game um thank you super chat thank
you thank you uh as a working adult i have no sympathy for
your story right now why would fast toky do this to me why
would she set up this trap Anyway, so I was in the middle of
a call with my manager because I went to pick up my food
because I was like, oh, we have to we stop the can we stop
the uh stop for a bit I need to go get food and I came back
and I was just like uh, so they found out I'm a streamer and
I was like to my manager like do I move like I'm like what
do I what what do I do I do I do I need a a new place to
live now and then and then he was like oh that's funny and
i'm like what do you what do you mean that's funny and
because he was like oh what if oh it's fine they're like
what they might be like 40 to 50 year olds like you know and
i'm like no they're like they're like sort of my age so it's
like a little scarier and then he was like oh yeah no that's
bad He's like, what, your neighbor's like, like middle age,
right?
And I was like, no, they're the, they're the young, they're
the young couple.
They're like sort of my age.
And he was like, oh, wait, no, that's a lot worse.
That might be a lot worse.
Yeah, I don't know, maybe.
Like, I don't know.
And I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think it is a little weird.
knowing my neighbors know I'm a streamer I think also
doesn't help that I always get a lot of packages whether
it's PR packages or like something related to like a sponsor
I'm doing or like merch and stuff so I always get packages
outside my door so they might be like that's weird you know
so yeah so I that's where consent they know how to Google
you know like they just like the context i say so they're
like now now there's like they they know how to use
technology better than like someone who's middle-aged or
older like so yeah and yeah so i'm just like oh no they're
they're tech literate yeah ever consider how patria has to
think of a super chat thank you thank you i have been i
actually been like sort of looking at houses and stuff like
on and off the last like I live is just very expensive.
So I'm just like, um, I think I would rather and also like,
I don't want to take care of a house.
I rather just own an apartment, whether instead, because
like, there's also a lot of amenities.
Um, like a lot of amenities are provided.
You live in an apartment building and, uh, yeah, house in
this economy right now.
It's, it's a little rough.
Um, uh, uh, I'll say, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're in Doki's chat where was i'm jealous thank you super
chat thank you thank you yeah and also like it's a lot more
to clean too uh can you see no there's no it's not dokeybird
it just it's just like i don't have any anything that's
addressed to dokeybird goes to like my po box which by the
way i need to tweet the new po box address but the new po
box address is now with my new distributor but i forgot to
tweet that that's why in the schedule you don't see me tweet
the new peel box but the peel box address is the new one on
my youtube channel so you guys ever want to send me anything
um the peel box peel box address is updated on my youtube
channel i just forgot i just haven't tweeted it out yet um
but anything that's addressed to doughkeeper it goes
straight to my peel box anything addressed directly to me
goes to me uh to like with my name on it mr mr broken bond
think of chat thank you thank you uh guess you have to help
keep them safe now angriest thank you super chat thank you
thank you um cyber thank you with super chat thank you thank
you hi doki's neighbor i know you're here do me a favor and
make her clean her room thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you yeah i'm like thinking i'm like debating on
whether because i have been looking at it because i've been
like thinking after i get my bank stuff situated so oh yeah
also like i was i was stuff today too like i said i was
doing getting i was going through a lot of backlog i just
had to sit me down it was like you can't run away this time
like he's like he was like we'll have to cancel a stream if
you delay again it's like no not my streams anything he
tried to help he was holding my streams hostage he had he
has the power by the way because he has access to my youtube
channel so he has the power to delete a waiting room so like
no not the waiting room please
my mistake no don't break them into this um so uh yeah he
was gonna hold my stream sausage so so i was going to your
bank so i hate my bank i hate my bank so much so we were
missing one statement that to send over but like it was like
a statement that like doesn't exist online so i have to go
to my branch to ask them to provide me the statement because
the bank was like, oh my God, I hate my bank.
I hate it so much.
Like I, my other Canadian staff member was like, because
we're telling her, we're like, I can't access statements
past 18 months.
And then my staff member was like, I hate your bank.
I hate this company.
I was like, I hate them.
I hate them so much.
And I swear, Canadian banks are like stuck in the stuck in
the 90s I still have no this is we're finishing up all the
paperwork for it and the moment we finish this paperwork I
can switch banks and like the so like we're almost finishing
up the stuff that would let me switch banks
so so basically for some fucking reason my bank uh my
particular bank does not allow me to access any statements
past 18 months which is fucking crazy why is there a limit
to it oh i'm sorry did they not have in the bandwidth to
store all our statements or some shit like there's like an
expiration date for bank statements and so i'm not i can't
access any bank statements past 18 months and like i had and
then i was like how the fuck do i access it then because
we're missing a particular statement um just what this was
the last thing i need to provide and it was like past 18
months and um because they needed that one they're like oh
we need this month because we realized it wasn't in our
records like uh for what i um for what i'm trying to do and
then so then um to like my accountant and then i was just
like, oh, okay, um, I have to go to the branch.
I have to go to the fucking branch in person to request it.
And I have to go in person.
I'm like, what's the point?
What's the point?
Like, why have anything online if I still have to go in
person?
Yeah, and then there'll be a fee.
And apparently, if I make this request, I have to pay a fee
to access it.
like i have to pay a fee to access a statement that's past
18 months um so no and then and oh my god it's so stupid so
it's so dumb so i have to go in person to access it
basically but also don't know my particular bank also does
not allow you to do like wire transfers online you have to
do it in person too like every time i do a wire um it's why
i set up a wise account because i was so i know i have to
pay a fee if i uh by setting up a wise account but i i was
like i cannot keep going in person just to do wire transfers
because it's just so much work and it's like they they i i
i'm also like very paranoid because one time they fucked up
a wire transfer um yeah so they fucked up a wire transfer
one time it was a big amount of money and they they met they
had a typo in like one person that the person was doing it
had a had a really bad typo where they accidentally put an
extra letter in the wire transfer and i didn't notice
because there's so many things i have to check and as like i
thought i i missed that one section where they did they
because yeah i had to double check to after they're done
typing everything out they gave it to me to double check and
i missed that one section um where they had a typo in it and
I didn't notice and then I the the recipient of the wire
transfer was like hey we couldn't the bank won't let us take
the money because there's a typo in here that there's like a
one letter typo so we need you to fix this and then I had to
go back to the bank in person and be like hey you fucked up
there's a typo and they're like well we um well you have to
pay a fee to get this fixed and I was like this was your
mistake like what do you fee this was you fucked up the yeah
but it was your responsibility to check if there's a typo
because you approved it and I'm like oh just fuck pay the
fee pay the fuck I don't like there was nothing I could do
like yeah so like at that point I just wanted to get this
sorted I didn't want to argue for too long because like I
was just done and it was like a sink it was I had to pay the
so that it was a big amount of money too so i don't want to
drag it out too long
and oh my god it was so fucking frustrating anyway i hate my
bank i i absolutely hate my bank oh so yeah so i was like
going through that um and everything but i was like i've
been looking at places um kuka thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you as someone who works in finance i feel
your pain our main ledger system is from the 80s paper and
excel is king in finance computers are expensive they give
the super chat they can thank it but yeah like i think in
canada too i'm pretty sure it's a canadian mostly canadian
thing where we have to do wire transfers in person um if
you're like doing it from your bank i i use wise now uh if i
have like a lot of wire transfers because like i can't keep
going to the bank in person on and off and also i don't
trust them to like i i like i and then after that incident i
always gets also like I'm so paranoid that because like if I
do wire transfers online at least I can copy and paste the
information that they give me so I know there's no like
mistakes but then in person I print the information out I
hand it to them and then they have to retype all the
information and there's more margin of errors for them to do
that so that's why I was like so I now rely on wise to do my
journey of my wire transfer because it's the only way I can
do it online um because like there's no online system with
my bank like also all that one time some guy recognized me
too that and also throw it back to that one time that one
guy at the bank recognized me because they um because it has
my because one of my i had to like change my company uh i
had like uh one of my under Doki Bird.
So then I don't use that account anymore, but I still had
stuff in.
I couldn't, at that time, I wasn't able to close that
account yet.
So I had to, so I still had like some stuff I had to do on
that account before I could close it.
And then, so like one of the bank members, I told the story
before, but one of the tellers was like, are you Doki Bird?
And then I'm like, you know, I, I've just didn't hear this
story before.
I was like, oh, no, I work for her.
I had to be like, no, I work for her.
It's like, so that also, like, every time I see that guy,
because I remember his face, every time I see that guy, I
would always, like, wait until, like, I would wait until,
like, someone else, like, I'll just, like, go to, like,
occupy the guy, and then I'll take someone else.
because I don't want to like I can't like he's gonna
recognize my voice that's the thing like and I can't hold a
long conversation with him knowing that he knows my voice
like like I like yes I will change my voice if I talk to him
but like I'd rather not risk it you know like and it's like
I'd rather I'd rather not fucking risk it um So I'm just
like, oh my God, I hate my bank so much.
It's all, oh, I hate my bank so much, guys.
Also, so yeah, oh yeah, anyway, back to what I was saying
about, yeah, I've been looking at places lately, looking at
places to buy, like not places, sorry, a place, I'm not
gonna, I'm gonna have a vacation home in Paris, guys.
I'm not, guys, I'm not that rich, guys, I swear to God.
I'm not that rich.
I'm looking at multiple places.
I'm going to have vacation home in New York City.
I'm looking at a place...
I've been looking at places right now for just like a
permanent place to live.
Because I've been renting my whole life.
I've moved around a lot.
Like I said, I've been debating on whether or not I want to
live here where I'm currently living because it is expensive
but it is where I was born um like so it's like you know a
lot of memories are associated to city I'm in and but I know
it's not very convenient as a streamer like it it's not I
mean it's convenient in a way where like everything is
nearby but everything is nearby I have fiber internet and
everything and so like i know the place really well but it's
also like it is an expensive place to live so like i've been
thinking about like do i want to if i if i'm owning a place
do i want to live here you know like
yeah so but it'd be easier to move all my stuff around if i
stay here i've also debated about like I was like, please,
Toki, don't move to LA.
I have debated about that, too.
I was like, but what if I moved to LA, though?
Because also, if you're a content creator, LA is the place
to be.
Because I'm already paying, where I live is already really
expensive.
But then I was like, but also, do not know, Toki, don't go
into the, don't eat the apple.
They're like, Toki, no!
Don't eat the apple!
Don't fall for the meme!
Do not move to America!
It's a trap, Toki!
That's what they want you to do!
And the Dalai only survives because they tricked all the
content creators to live there.
Come to California, Doki.
The fires are so warm here.
And I see they give us a super chat.
Thank you, Doki.
Don't listen to the voices.
That's what they want.
They want another sacrifice, another victim.
It's a pyramid scheme, Doki.
Don't do it.
She wants to assimilate.
so no no one of the reasons why biggest reason why i'm like
i'm leaning towards staying in canada is because also i get
paid in american dollars so as a canadian if if you've ever
as if you americans ever go to canada with your american
money you will feel like a king it's like when we go to
japan um when we go to japan and like our at least our
currency right now uh against yen is also like pretty good
for us too so like yeah like so you if you come to canada
you'll feel your american money will make you feel like a
king because our currency is so bad right now
$10 cheaper.
It was wild.
So I'm like, well, I do get paid in American dollars, like
with sponsors and merch and like YouTube wise.
I mean, they pay me like they converted to Canadian, but
then when I get conversion, I'm like, whoa, wow.
So even though where I live is expensive, I can make use of
my money.
I can stretch my money more than if I go to america yeah so
so that's nice you know it's we do pay a lot of taxes but
that's you know it is it is nice uh ho and george thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you come to new york city
we have more rats than man there's rats where i live too i
there would be like rats randomly like you i would walk down
the street and i'll just see a rat walking running a cross
the sidewalk i'm like whoa and then i would just be like
whoa like what's that and then now he's used to it now he's
used to the rats now um not the pvp zone uh let's see what
else is there um but yeah i'm most likely i think i've i
mean i have been looking at like i it just depends on like
how much i want to pay for for like uh because i don't know
about i don't know anything about mortgages or anything so
because i'm doing this all by myself so that's what i'm most
uh i almost say scared more so like uh stressed out about
because like this is my first time by like looking at houses
to or apartments to live live in and i don't really know the
process and like mortgages and all of that i don't know
anything i'm very hesitant because i'm all i'm so confused
um i'm so confused confused I I feel like a baby I feel like
a little chud um and yeah so like I have to learn all of
that too um uh but yeah uh what else what else I want to
talk about oh before oh yes yes I know I said I would leave
it I saw it I saw the updated leaderboards but guys guys
guys look we improved They took into account data that
should not have been taken into account.
They should release the files.
I need to know the analysis of the data.
I want to see all the numbers, how they got to that
decision.
Because all I'm going to say is that they took into account
some streams that should not have been added into the data.
And by the way, we improved, though.
We are climbing the leaderboards.
Improvement is step by step.
It's not an overnight thing, guys, all right?
You guys, we are at half season.
We are at half season right now.
This is the half season mark.
We're not done yet, dragons.
Like, we're not, it's not like it's done.
It's like, we're like midway.
It's midseason.
We're not at the end.
We're not, the season hasn't ended.
Like, ha ha ha ha.
We climbed Elo.
We went from bronze 5 to bronze 4.
That's improvement.
We're going to get our rank up soon, guys.
Our rank up is there.
It's literally right there.
Did I not start at exactly 5?
What about that?
We are at the midterms.
Guys, we haven't done...
The finals hasn't started yet.
My build is an endgame build.
I'm an endgame build.
We just got to keep farming.
Until we're there.
My alt is...
I'm at 50% on my alt, dragons.
Like, we're endgame build.
I'm scaling.
We're just scaling.
Like, yeah, late game.
We're late game.
We're...
So there's...
So there's still...
Guys, guys, we saw improvement.
We saw improvement.
So...
That means we're heading in the right direction.
I just need to do 10 more streams to before the end of the
season.
We're gonna farm.
Don't whip your up.
Yes, we're getting plus 10, we're getting plus 10 Elo every
stream, guys.
It's okay.
Oh, look, this is what I hate.
This is what I hate.
I feel like the matchmaking system is so fucked up.
Oh, I was, I won every other game, but every, I won majority
of the game.
But, oh, I lost two matches and then they took away 50% of
my ELO.
Like, what the fuck is this bullshit system?
That's why I said they should release the matchmaking data.
I demand him to release the matchmaking data.
I can't believe I lose 50% of my progress because I lost two
games.
games out of what eight out of eight streams two streams
fucked up my data like what is this match making what is
this matchmaking system the i feel like i feel like the uh
matchmaking system is skewed like i all i'm saying is that
there is a e-o-m-m agent somewhere and it's not me it's
balanced all i'm saying is that they should release it um
they should release a mid-patch i feel like they should buff
and nerf certain things and he should release a mid-patch to
to make the matchmaking more fair uh this is me and god i
demand a hot fix right now
All right, anyway, all right, but this is how I felt when I
saw it, but this is actually how I felt when I saw the
lyrics.
Let me see if I can find the meme.
This is how I felt when I saw it.
Where's the template?
This is me.
When I first, when I saw the, I, all I'm saying, improvement
is improvement.
Guys, we just, we just, we ranked up a tier, and that's all
that mattered.
We ranked up, like, plus one.
If we didn't lose Elo, we gained Elo, guys.
We should be proud of ourselves.
We played 10 games, and we gained Elo.
We didn't go even.
We went up.
This is me.
True.
This is us right now.
Iron 3 to Iron 2.
Elo is Elo.
Don't worry.
It's the mid-season.
We're late game built.
We're late build.
Look at me in the next 10 streams.
The next 10 games.
There will be another update.
and we will be on the leaderboards.
Also, alright.
So, today we're going to be playing House.
House 2, in fact.
For those who don't know this game, you must be like, how
did you find this game?
Oh my god, you're playing a horror game willingly.
So, House, for those who didn't know, like, lore, some Bark
Knight loreers.
Some OG Bark Knights might remember this.
house, the first game was one of the first streams I've ever
done as a VTuber.
So like I officially debuted around that time, like five
plus years ago.
And the first house game was that like we even have the VODs
uploaded too on the channel.
If you guys want to watch the first house VOD.
And it was the one of very first games I've ever streamed as
a VTuber.
You know, I have been streaming before as Joki, but like
this is the first stream I've done as like an actual VTuber
VTuber.
so that's like the, so recently, after five years, the game
finally came out.
I didn't even think this game would ever, I didn't even
realize this game was going to get a sequel because the
first game, it was a very, it was like a standalone game.
Like it had its own ending and everything.
It was a very, it was a very unique story in a way.
It like loops over and over basically.
So you're supposed to you have a set, I don't know, I'm
pretty sure it's very similar.
So It's basically in the first game, you have a set timer of
what you can and can't do in the game for the day.
And then if you fail it, the game ends and you have to do it
all over again.
So it's all about getting all the sequences correct during
like, so every time you, every sequence, you learn more and
more stuff on how to beat the game.
So if you fail, you go back from the beginning, but you
learn like, oh, maybe I should have done this.
maybe I should have done that so it's not essentially
roguelike it's just learning because it resets everything
it's like a time loop game so I don't know if house 2 is I
assume house 2 is very similar where you learn like every
time you learn something new um you're trying you're trying
your best to learn something new and trying to figure out
like how to beat the game so like you're just it's just
trying to figure out how to beat the game because the first
couple of times you play it you don't really know what's
going on um yeah it's a trial and error so i beat the
original game um but it took me a lot of try it took me a
lot of loops to figure it out um obviously bark knights
helped along too being like oh maybe you should do that that
blah blah um and your goal there's several endings to unlock
i think i got the true i think i don't know if i got the
true ending i remember like we uh there's several endings i
think i like two of the endings two or three of i don't know
It like it was five years ago.
I knew like You can either let your family die And you save
yourself or you save your family members.
I don't remember who I saved I saw my sister died several
times like I remember laughing about one of them because
Because I was like what the fuck like Because I was like
don't worry she's safe and then she fucking dies And I'm
like oh shit like I remember there was like a clip of I did
clip I I remember someone clipped it and I posted on Twitter
because I thought it was really fucking funny um solid thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you check to va
dragon she is 3d very cute has many hand gestures and flips
you off thank you for this super chat thank you thank you uh
she's safe she was not safe um but I assume this would be
similar um the original game the graphics was in like
pixelated it was pixel so I saw the trailer for House 2 and
there's definitely much more detail much more gory by the
way in the first game it was more so like in your
imagination of how like it was like the gourd there wasn't
really actual like gourd factor in like me there was gourd
but it was like pixelated gourd so like but that's not a
trailer for this and I was like oh the depths are much
they like it was five years they definitely up the graphics
of it like up the intensity of the game
so um so i guess we'll see how it goes i'm very excited um
yeah they up the ante up the quality um it is the sequel
they have five years i assume they have invested more they
invested more into this game as well um um because the first
game was really I actually really I remembered the first
game I I remember enjoying the first game it was a very
interesting concept in itself um and this one has new art
style and everything much more detail uh I remember someone
in in the comments was talking about how it reminds of um
what was it called the Frank Bo Frank I don't remember what
the game was called like you know the the little girl that
like mint the apparently the art style is very similar to
the to that frank game that look that little girl um um fran
bow yeah little misfortune that's those that's what i was
thinking of yeah so the art style apparently is very similar
to little misfortune fran bow oh um so i'm excited to check
it out and see like you know uh what new mechanics they've
introduced and uh and uh just like what uh what mechanics
they've introduced and you know what what's new about it too
because i in the ritual game you're i escaped so it's like
what happened did she just stumbled like she got adopted and
then like um it's happening again in a new house like i'm
like i thought she lit like i well i escaped so i'm like
what's is this a new family is this a new story or it out
and find out i know like there was not a lot of reviews for
this game but from the reviews i did see it was positive it
was a very it has positive reviews so um i hope it's just as
good as the original i like i said i really enjoyed the
original i remember it finally and it looks like it's very
has very positive reviews um and um can't wait to try out
with you guys it's not I don't know if it's, I don't know if
it's a short game.
I don't know if it's a long game.
I didn't look at too many spoilers for this.
But I remember the first game was pretty, was like, if you
get the loop correct, if you figure out how to beat the game
early on, like, you can make it a very quick game.
But if it takes me a lot, like, I'm more brain-rodded now.
I'm not as smart as five years ago, Doki.
I will say after five years, I might be more dumb than five
years ago, Doki.
We, it might take, but, but I do have more backseaters this
time around.
So, like, you guys are, like, taking into account of my IQ
points.
You're, I will say I might have regressed.
I'm very confident about that fact that I definitely have
regressed as a person.
But I do have more backseaters now, though.
I, so you guys will make up for my, for the brain cells I've
lost over the years.
yeah so let's let's try this out let's play the game guys uh
i hope sound guys here today um because i don't know if i
don't know if the sound balancing is correct all right yeah
i had i critical i'd use my critical thinking skills a lot
more five years ago
Is this the consequences of not using my...
I'm relying on backseating a bit too much?
Oh, wait.
Okay, this is perfect.
Wait, okay, I need to restart.
Okay, I thought it was really funny because while dad was
barking, the loading screen was like, bark, bark.
I'll feed him if he dead.
Well, this loads...
Give me a sec, I'm feeding dad.
Did you guys see it?
Did you guys see park, park?
I thought it was funny.
The moment...
Oh, wait, let me turn it.
This game down.
I thought it was funny, and then it was like, park, park.
What's better than one house?
Two houses.
So true.
Oh, the art style.
It looks very gloomy.
Oh, I've...
Oh, this is a controller game.
You guys want to know how I know that it's a controller
game?
Because...
Um...
To click...
To start the game, it's A.
But, like, on my keyboard.
It's...
It's a...
What's funny is I remember the original was a controller
game.
That's the name.
I had to click A on my keyboard.
So I was like, oh.
He was on controller.
It's not entered.
It was A.
Specifically A on the keyboard.
Oh, there's no audio setting.
You're so right.
There isn't.
five years to remove the audio I don't even remember the
original game had audio
all right hit press the triangle on your keyboard to accept
the fact that's a on the keyboard oh wait this is the
original family oh can't he see go wait this is the original
what did i do did i come back to my what happened how did i
came back home you interrupt your regularly scheduled
programming for an urgent weather update okay severe storms
are moving through the region tonight with intense rainfall
sweeping the nation joining us live for his first and
possible last field report is hugh james hugh what can you
tell us is that as bad as it looks Oh, he's not happy.
Thanks, Nadia.
It's as bad as it looks.
As you can see, I'm completely soaked.
I've been out here for hours questioning every...
Get an umbrella.
What?
That's a choice.
We urge everyone to remain indoors during these
unprecedented conditions.
Unlike me, stay safe out there, folks.
Oh, that does look like a place.
Oh!
Guys, I think he's okay.
Lightning never strikes twice.
Oh, hello, mom.
That's me!
Hi, girls.
I hope I didn't start on YouTube.
Okay, the mom did not look like this, by the way.
I don't know.
Because the sister, the sister and the main character, um,
they look, they're the same characters as the original house
game.
But the mom, that's not what my mom looked like.
Let's just say that's like, I mean, your favorite frog leg
soup come downstairs and let's eat the original mom the mom
did not look like that before yeah she's just like me look
wait i don't have it oh wait that's actually wait what i
actually came came back wait that's what happened to me last
time.
Yeah, I lost my arm in the first game.
Why would I come back?
Why would I keep living in this house?
Okay.
Oh, I need a controller where I can see the symbols.
I don't like that.
items I'll look at myself
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary Bloody Mary Am I getting closer?
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Alright, I'm good.
Guys, I think Bloody Mary worked.
Do it.
Alright.
Oh yeah, I remember in the first house.
Yeah, in the first game, I killed my dad.
So in the first game, I guess this is like if I do true
ending where I saved everyone.
Because the mom also at one point, she elongates her, her,
uh, uh, she elongates her neck at one point.
I'm like vaguely remembering it.
I the thing the worst part is that I knew that was gonna
happen too I love you tulip swim free my little babies I
remember like in one air in one section like the neck goes
longer oh they're so happy this is the same kitchen is that
Not my mom.
Who is she?
I know it's not much, but I hope you're happy here.
Can I take anything?
Oh, it's the answer, grandma.
Oh, she's gone.
Oh, I guess my parents died.
Oh, it's inviting me outside.
Surely not for bad things.
Oh!
I'm so clumsy.
Hey there.
Hey.
I don't have much time, but you're in real trouble.
I can't say much even that.
of getting down very slightly okay let me know it's better
you know they got their eye on this i'm still trying to
figure out when and where i am sorry uh trust no one
question everything i'll see you around oh oh i have a disc
now all right yeah if the true ending you lose your arm I
remember that.
Because I remember looking at up all the endings too.
Alright, I brought the game down slightly.
Okay.
Oh, no, we spilled pepper.
Not pepper.
Hey, grandma slash auntie.
Rain, rain, you'll never go away.
Oh, hi, Tabby.
Oh.
The roof isn't leaking.
She's so flexible, bottle.
She's so flexible.
Wait, maybe I might.
Maybe I'll play it at...
Oh!
She seemed like a safe man.
Hello there, sir.
What would you like to do?
This here came with ship-free shipping to the world.
Imagine that.
Alright.
See you guys?
Talking to strangers is okay.
Let's check this out.
Bark station.
Kimiko's curse?
Why is my sister playing?
It was my game.
Oh my god, they made...
They finally made a sequel to Kimiko's curse after five
years.
It's been years.
And then she finds another game, and then she plays, uh, she
plays apartments too.
Dear Kimiko, I, oh, do you guys know, like, uh, Gen Z can't
read cursive, can't read cursive?
Gen Z and younger, because they've, uh, what's the word?
They've, uh, taken the game out, uh, sorry, the game.
They've taken it out of the curriculum.
Yeah.
So they're not being taught cursive anymore.
I swear, you and your, I'm sure you and your, and father are
worried sick about me.
I've gone home to be with mother.
I hope you'll come visit soon.
Your sister, Yukiko.
Yeah, they're not, they're not teaching cursive anymore.
So Gen Z and Younger can no longer read or write cursive.
Because it's like, there was like no point in teaching it
anymore.
Uh, 27 Kikiyama Street, CT.
Oh, there it is.
Looks very inviting.
I love how the eyes are...
The house's eyes are very welcoming.
Hello?
I wonder if they complete the game at, like, a certain pace.
Oh, I don't like that.
It's like a game within a game.
Oh, hello.
Okay, I'm just gonna spam it.
Okay.
Ha!
Oh, my fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm just gonna spam A.
I got him.
This is a very hard game.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, I'm a horse.
You pee.
Oh, game over.
Um, stop backseating me.
I know what I'm doing.
Oh my god, I keep going backwards.
Alright, I haven't...
Kinko, what are you doing here?
Letter?
I didn't send you any letters.
I closed my eyes and woke up here.
I can't remember anything.
I couldn't find mommy anywhere.
You can save us again, right?
Okay.
Oh, I need her to follow me.
Oh, it's so...
Alright.
Is that not you, Kinko?
Well, how the fuck am I supposed to?
Oh, my God, it's him again.
Okay.
There you go.
I blocked it.
Get blocked.
Ah, fuck.
It doesn't matter what my HP is, anyway.
Well, obviously, that's a crack for something.
Oh, I found more battery.
Oh.
I mean, maybe it's somewhat...
People have hobbies.
Oh, fuck.
That's a zombie.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it does that whole heart.
No!
Okay.
There you go.
I timed it.
You need to raise it?
There you go.
All right.
Block.
Nice.
I got an axe.
What do I do with the axe, though?
Have I been here?
Wait, no.
I like the sound of that.
Oh!
You're here again?
Okay, nice block.
Alright.
Okay, so the axe is stronger.
Oh my god, I already been here.
Okay.
Hello?
Yukiko?
Are you down here?
Yukiko, I'm your sister!
Oh!
Hello, mom!
My sweet daughter.
What took you so long?
Now come give mommy a kiss.
That's not true.
you kiss your mama whoa get blocked mama your reflexes are
lacking wow oh shit i'm sorry mama am i not doing any damage
to her do i just die oh double
no it's enough kiss i'm giving her a kiss oh i like how much
my thought do i can i even beat this
Am I even supposed to beat it?
I'm leaving.
Yes.
I haven't been playing for.
Did you like that game?
You can keep playing.
I don't want to see what happens next.
How long have we been playing for?
I know, right?
It's so fucked up.
She hogged the entire game.
No, I'm trying to close the light.
I wonder if she dies.
Oh, okay, I turned it off here.
Okay, there's my bedroom.
I got like a new home, mighty.
Oh, the house just followed me.
So this is new.
Home doodles.
Can I turn like nothing I can?
Oh, there we go.
Ever since we left the house, everything has felt so
strange.
Waking up to a new gate, new day, every day.
doing ordinary things it feels wrong somehow to feel safe to
feel like I found a place to go home I don't know about that
I don't think it's we'll go to sleep I
don't know if safe is the right word to what's going on
clock tick tock tick Tick, talk, tick, talk, tick, talk,
tick, talk, tick, talk, as long as there's no murderers yet.
Mickey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm living with a neighbor.
6 p.m.
All right.
I woke up so late.
I feel so dizzy.
It's time for another adventure.
Alright, let's go.
Come on, Tavi.
Let's go play!
Come on!
Look at my...
I got a snail on my head.
Oh!
Scrub, scrub, scrub.
Oh, what do I...
Oh, I'm...
I guess, like, if there's any puddles.
Is it?
Oh, there's gotta be puddles or something.
Oh, that looks like a very safe...
Okay.
That looks very safe.
I'm trying to grab it.
I'm not allowed to grab the cheese.
Why can't I grab the cheese?
i want the cheese wait there's a god damn it scrub scrub
scrub scrub scrub there we go i cleaned the pee they have
pee on my feet do i do the dishes for me please oh my god
it's your turn to do the dishes do that because it is capped
Oh.
Oh my god, I want to turn on the lights.
What do I do with this?
That's the only show, Lewis.
Oh, no, my baseball!
Oh, no, that might have been important.
Oh, no.
I wish.
My wife's at Susie Circus.
Oh, it's over here.
Where's my cat going?
Oh.
Is my cat going to be okay?
Guys.
I don't know if my cat's going to be okay.
I...
Um...
Scrub, scrub, scrub
Toki, what you mean, cat?
Toki, what do you mean, cat?
Hello?
Oh, that meant I'm- oh, that meant I fucked up.
What?
Scrub, scrub, scrub?
Oh, I got the pie, though.
Got a knife.
Stab, stab, stab.
Ow!
Ah!
Okay.
Got banana peel.
Stab, stab, stab.
It says I can cycle through stuff, but...
Or, like, swap weapons, but that's a lie.
I'm gonna run with my knife.
Oh, okay.
Friendly?
Stab!
Oh!
I didn't realize how...
Well, am I...
Don't you hate it when your aunt starts draining you of your
life force?
Don't you hate it when that happens?
Like...
Alright, here we go again.
You know what grabs my gears?
When my...
When my aunt fucking...
Ah, god!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, there's not a lot of...
There's not a lot of controls, yet for some reason, I can't
do all of these.
I feel like I have to let that happen.
Okay, I gotta go lure the dog before my cat dies.
Oh, she's not watching TV yet.
Oh, my aunt seems happy for now.
Oh, shit, the dog!
The dog!
Okay.
Alright, but it doesn't matter about clearing the piss, I
feel like.
I feel like what matters is, oh, the dog's not here.
I'm sure the dog chases me.
Oh, hot!
Fuck!
I hesitated.
It'll be fine.
Surely my sister isn't gonna trip on the stairs and die.
It'll be okay.
Look, we'll watch this.
Oh?
Why is he here already?
You shouldn't be here yet.
Okay, we're gonna get the dog.
It'll be fine.
Surely my sister's not gonna slip on the piss and die.
There we go.
Dog, come in here, dog.
Come on.
We gotta figure out the loop.
Dog.
Okay, I have the idea.
You get the dog, and then you loop it.
to the trap.
We gotta figure it to loop out.
That's right.
What you gotta do, die?
Nothing.
And then I'll set the trap up again.
Just in case.
I did it!
I saved my cat!
See?
If anything, we'll save at least one family member.
Look, my sister is fine.
See?
oh shit oh shit oh shit back up back up back up all right
see nothing to worry about and you guys were so worried that
my sister was gonna slip look at that she's fine saved at
least one person has been saved today all
right what are my cats gonna do why did he have to go this
way meow meow oh wait where is she going huh oh oops all
right Oh Fuck, oh shit Ah No, why did I?
It's really not It's okay Oh Oops Oh Oh Oops I Chucky, why
did you set her up?
I didn't think that was...
I didn't think you would walk into the trap.
Oh, oh no, no.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Yeah, why did he step on the trap?
Is he fucking stupid?
Okay.
Sap!
Oh, God.
I don't have a lot of stabs left.
Stab!
Oh, that's a creepy doll.
That must be my sister.
Stab!
Oh, that killed her?
Oh, she's dead.
I think that's my sister.
She got turned a metal-deleast decaying body sprawled on the
floor.
Can I go that way?
Time flies when you're having fun, doesn't it?
All right, so that's how you kill her.
Oh, the night's coming.
Okay, maybe the door is fine now.
All right, I mean, I killed one of the demons.
The trap that kills one pet can't possibly kill the other.
That's what I saw!
Oh, shit, everything is trying to kill me.
Maybe the one pot.
Oh, God, everything is trying to kill me.
Everything is trying to kill me.
Kuka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where do I go?
Oh, hey, the baseball.
Maybe I'll watch TV.
All right, TV doesn't work.
Oh.
At least I'll have.
I guess she was just...
Tabby?
Tabby, what did you do?
Guys, I saw...
I accidentally...
I think I saw...
I accidentally softlocked the game, guys.
I wasn't supposed to stab him while I was trying to grab
Tabby.
I softlocked it.
No!
I didn't think that was possible.
Some things really do say the same.
The stabbing tank would die like cause a stoplight.
I didn't know!
Oh yeah, Snepi.
I didn't know he would just...
I don't know.
I thought maybe he would still be alive.
Oh, is that supposed to know he just died?
Oh, do I have to stab her again?
I know you would just die.
Okay, note to self.
Do not reopen the trap.
I didn't think you would step on the trap.
Okay.
I still really understand the why button.
Oh, I guess like cycle action or something maybe.
Okay.
We got that out.
You'll grab the baseball.
I don't know what the baseball does, but we'll grab the
baseball.
Okay, don't stab.
Do not stab the...
Okay, so that's the creepy doll.
Do not stab the tank.
There's nothing here.
Turn the lights on.
Is there anything here I can grab?
Okay, we'll grab, we'll deal with the dog first.
Dog first.
Alright.
Dog.
Alright, dog dead.
Creepy.
The dog, dokey, the dog just wanted to eat.
He was just so hungry.
He was starving.
Okay, scrub, scrub, scrub, and then my sister will be fine.
First step done.
And then step.
I don't know if I need to do anything.
I mean, the rat will get himself killed.
So I just need the cat to...
Does the cat go yet?
No, the cat's still up there.
Oh, yeah, that wash.
Oh, that's why my sister died.
scrub scrub scrub scrub scrub scrub oh shit okay scrub scrub
scrub steal the pie maybe but all right everyone should be
happy now right oh
let me kill the cockroach too oh okay the knife will fall
come on at least let me see this murder.
One murder done.
Alright.
My cat should be down here now.
Cat?
Yeah!
Cat!
What did I get?
Oh, it's ammo!
Okay.
The ammo will be for something.
I don't know what.
Alright, now I have to go kill my fake neighbor.
Oh, she's fine.
Doesn't seem to be dying or anything.
Oh!
Okay.
Everybody seems to be alive.
Oh, the doll's gone.
Oh.
My sister is not...
Oh, another roach.
Oh, goodbye, roach.
It's 10, 17.
Alright, this time.
Okay.
Alright.
I got...
He's with me this time.
Oh!
There's blood on the floor.
Oh.
Is everybody okay?
Oh!
She deflated.
Oh, maybe I have to give her the pie.
Maybe that's what I have to do.
I'm where I almost killed her.
The pie in this trap.
The shimmy.
The little shimmy.
Me and my snails.
Got this.
Oh, I burnt it.
Oopsie.
What do I do with the pie?
I have a burnt pie.
I'm At least I have another stab.
Oh, hey, there's a frog.
Hey, frog.
Stab?
Stab.
Wait, maybe I can step on it.
Stop!
Stop me!
Oh.
Daddy's home.
Wait, Daddy's less scary, though.
I will sit.
I think Daddy's gonna come over here.
Watch this.
Haha, what you gonna do, huh?
Ha ha ha!
Oh, shit, okay.
I...
Stap!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Stop!
Don't worry We can out we can help maneuver him Sam
Holy shit this man's a fucking tank Oh, no, oh, no, I don't
I I didn't manage my stamina guys It's okay.
It's okay We will get there Oh
Alright Oh god Yeah, I'm in max our stat.
We have managers our resources here There's competitive
stabbing Oh, shit.
Oh, shit Snoopy are you looking No
Shit, that was pretty gory I'm competitive.
Oh my god I didn't run.
I played too close to the sun Perry dokey Perry We were
halfway Wait I think I got this Congrats thank you Welcome
to tomato farm Welcome welcome Your dad was not playing Me
that's for sure Why do I keep it open it'll do anything Okay
let's get the There's some loop, basically.
I assume I have to do the pie.
I just don't know what time.
Maybe if I get the pie done at a right time, she won't be
angry.
Alright, dog time.
I don't think I need to worry too much about the dog.
Only because that
all right
wait the oven had a timer oh oh it does
oh does she
do I give it to her who do I give the pie to one first in
the county do I who do I miss the Titanic or have you seen a
who do I give the pie to I got a nice pie Who wants my pie
Pie It's pie time
Well I feel like My cat is my cat down Oh is it to Oh I
wouldn't have had to kill the dog Wait but then my cat would
have died Oh Oh Oh, I knew I forgot something.
I...
Well, it's clean now.
Hey, guys.
I did it.
I cleaned.
I...
Guys, I did it.
I cleaned it.
Guys, when...
I...
I guess.
I mean...
What else can I...
I do.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We will always want your pie to keep.
And you forgot it probably wasn't exactly.
It might not have been.
It might not have been imported.
All right.
Now that I remembered about.
Well, that means the hair abducted my.
Oh, where was the sponge again?
Oh, shit.
I forgot the sponge.
Don't worry, it's fine.
Tabby doesn't do anything yet.
Or the cat doesn't do anything yet.
Alright.
I have to flush the toilet.
I don't know if I...
There we go.
Toilet flushed.
Alright, pee.
P. Maybe I have to, like, maybe she doesn't want an
audience.
Yeah.
Good job.
Right now, pie.
Okay, we have...
Oh, this is bad.
I should have done pie first.
Okay.
I don't think that my cat's gonna do anything yet.
Alright.
Unless my cat doesn't...
As long as I'm faster than my cat, it should be fine.
Oh, I should have done pie first.
I should have done pie first.
How do you disarm?
Oh, the baseball!
Ah, the baseball!
Okay, wait, wait, pie.
Okay, wait.
I'll grab the baseball.
And then...
Disarm... Oh, but I don't know how to grab.
Okay, baseball will disarm the trap.
And then... Oh, God.
Cat stilled it.
Okay, we made it.
Now!
Baseball, baseball, baseball.
There you go.
okay okay okay i got pie pie
and then throw oh shit oh shit okay don't worry don't worry
i just gotta find the angle throw there you go there you go
cat's fine cat is healthy there we go look dog happy Who's a
good guy?
Men, poke and prod, and no, not no food.
Many eyes all watching.
She is not friend.
Maggie saw a rock, a rat talking, and then rat.
Room of friend, then cage, and men in movie, now here
hungry.
Want you to have food, want you to pet Maggie, please.
Maggie, Maggie, kick, hit, bad girl, back the hole.
Maggie better, fool, sleepy.
What a cute dog.
Alright, we found a way to grab...
Okay, we know the pattern to grab ammo now.
We know the cycle.
To each game, we learn something new.
Oh, God.
Okay, we have knife.
We have knife now.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
He's over here.
Alright, I'll wait for it.
where's the creepy oh no come on what do you want from me
wait I think my sister's dead
yep yep she's dead uh alright it's just me the cat and the
aunt and I think my aunt's gonna die here too I can't grab
the gnome, though.
Someone's, like, grabbed the gnome, but I can't grab it.
Here we go again.
They're all watching you, dude.
Drown in the water, fly to the sky.
Don't worry.
Just be happy.
Oh, there she is.
All right, time to stab.
Stab!
Oh!
Stab.
I missed time.
It's, like, resource management, you know?
Okay.
Last one.
I just don't know how to get into...
Can I stab you?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, well, we know we can't stab...
Jesus Christ, okay.
Okay.
We know we can't stab the pole.
But what else can we do?
Holy...
Holy shit, that's so gory.
When does the toilet come up?
Alright.
I need to figure out the other patterns for stuff.
I wonder if I can stab the clown.
Like, I don't know what to do here.
That's the thing.
Okay.
Alright, pie.
Alright, my sister would have died here.
I don't scrub the dishes.
I know.
Only I didn't have one arm.
Like, I don't know what else to do here.
Tabby, wash your hair.
Okay, after I grab pie.
Check on the washroom?
I guess.
But, like...
I need to grab pie.
She's looking for a pocketbook.
I didn't scrub it.
My sister's dead.
I forgot.
Whoops.
She's dead.
We just gotta accept it.
Alright, you wanna see my dead sister?
Alright.
You wanna see my sister die?
Oops.
Because that's how I save her.
Well, I figured out that loop.
What the fuck do I do with...
Well, figure that out.
I just need to figure out where to grab a gun.
Don't worry, I'll clean your blood.
I guess I can't clean your blood.
Oops.
Oh.
well okay
well she's dead i'll clean that i'll grab the knife okay now
it's back to stabbing time
i don't know how she comes up beyond i guess she like oh oh
she's like you're not supposed to be yeah all right our go
up oh shit oh shit okay we can't get he'll rip us apart that
that wasn't the trailer okay his mission is just telling us
we're not in the right area all right well i guess the only
thing i know how to do is stab okay okay now the only thing
i know how to do
All right, there we go.
There we go.
I think the clown would grab me here.
I think that looks very grabbable.
And knowing and being good at is very different.
No, I'm not, guys.
I'm going to see if I can kill that.
What?
Okay.
Where the fuck did that come from?
They came in with the fucking fridge.
Okay.
All right.
That's bullshit.
Okay.
Dad.
Pie.
Get fridged.
Can I walk past that?
I should be able Yeah, if I go this way, that should save me
Okay Alright then cat will pee
And I tell her I'll tell her I did it I already did do it
Alright Cat pee?
Cat pee?
Cat pee Cat pee Cat pee There you go.
Alright, nice.
Meow.
Alright.
Cat has peed.
I repeat.
Okay, I still have 13 seconds left.
Oh my god.
The cat's the most lethal thing in this entire game.
So we pre-fired.
Alright, dog.
Then toilet.
Boom.
And then.
What the fuck?
What was that?
Hello?
What are you?
The sound of joy.
A happy family.
Meaning chalk.
But here I sit in this pit.
My gift is forgiven, so I'm done.
My crime now forgiven.
And my tail fully spun.
He definitely did not look bright.
in shape.
Should you feel the need to yell?
Peer not, just shake the bell.
My gift is given.
Okay, what the fuck do I do with the bell?
Ah, shit.
What do I do with it?
Hit.
I don't know what to do with the bell.
Bell is good?
Alright, toilet time.
Alright, my sister.
No, I did do a trap.
Did I not?
Oh, it's a trap!
I did it!
Cat, cat, cat.
Oh, my God.
I'm faster.
Don't worry.
I got distracted by the bed.
Oh, my God.
I missed!
There we go.
Cat's fine.
Cat will be fine now.
out okay oh she's gonna step in the comically lie what the
fuck he took a picture i got distracted sure the fridge
won't fall on me all right there you go should i take a
picture of me is my sister okay where did my sister go I
flushed the toilet.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, that's what it does.
Maybe one day both of us can get out of here, Tabby.
I feel like you're running out of time.
Okay, she'll be safe here, just sitting there.
Okay.
Alright, and then I'll stab my aunt.
Oh, hey there.
Hey, guys.
Oh, they're playing poker.
All right, step
Okay The double team Oh my god, this is so bad for me
I didn't realize there was a I forgot there was a delay That
it was a fucking delay We did everything perfectly do all
right okay pie we did everything perfect pie okay now wash
dishes I didn't that's why I went back I didn't want to kill
her in front of them Okay, pre-fire.
Okay, baseball.
I need to figure out how to get gunned, though.
Okay.
Alright.
Clean.
Pie should be done.
Oh my god, we're being- We're so efficient right now.
Pie.
Okay.
bell okay we know about the bell all right nice all right we
got bell we're making good time time is being made time is
money okay the sister will be okay you see the vision i
don't know what to do with my snail
the ceiling fan?
Maybe I can do more with the we're moving right now.
We're moving.
I feel like I should be able to do more with stuff.
I mean, I have the
where do I throw this baseball at?
I don't know.
The spider in the clouds Was it maybe?
Buggy, let's try.
Oh shit.
We're just throwing it anywhere.
Yeah, but then it'll kill the dog.
The dog was friendly.
Guys?
It was a friendly dog.
I don't want to do it because he seemed really friendly.
I could stab the clown.
I feel like the clown's just gonna kill me.
You know?
Can I save the rat?
Why would I need to save the rat, though?
Alright, let's die here, I guess.
Oh!
Um...
What was that?
Uh...
Oh, I actually had goosebumps.
Um...
How long?
Guys, I actually had goosebumps when I saw him.
Holy shit.
I actually...
Oh my god, I actually had goosebumps.
Holy shit.
Okay, one last stab.
Oh!
What do I feed the horse, though?
Hey, guys.
Just having fun?
Oh.
That actually scared me.
Get Lois Salami knife away from my flute.
Oh.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh!
I don't know what to do with the horse, though.
I don't have any more food.
Oh, he's...
Daddy's coming.
Daddy's coming!
Oh, I'm gonna...
Get in position.
Oh, there he is.
Daddy's home.
All right.
This is the only thing I know to do.
We gotta loop him.
Right here.
I'm so scared.
I feel like I'm actually getting stabbed.
That was scream was so scary.
office girl.
I felt like I was actually getting stabbed in real time.
No.
No wonder my neighbors are like, are you a streamer?
Oh my god.
Oh I'll stab you he's so tanky i have to like make sure i
give enough space
oh my god i don't want to risk i don't want to get too
greedy i don't want to get too greedy
oh my god
i almost did again
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I got too greedy there.
This is tense.
This is actually so tense.
Oh, look, I'm-
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, please don't fall.
There's no fall.
Oh, my God.
I'm- It's so scary.
It's so tense right now.
This is the stab of the sentry.
Please, please don't fall.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god.
What's that?
Oh, he did it!
Your father kills daddy without any help.
Your father lies motionless.
You're relieved, but only for a second.
Unseen hands rewind the clock.
Everything begins to knit back together.
You can get YV-1 me in the backyard.
LMG.
The cycle begins.
Final destiny in the back, final backyard.
knife only one-me-one survivor kill your father
GG's that oh my sister and my cat lived and we have our dog
alright let's see if we can get other achievements oh I
little girl.
So you killed your dad.
Wow.
Do you want an award or something?
Not like it really matters.
It'll just come back again and again and again.
And it took you 42 minutes.
I guess that's decent.
Oh, it times me too.
Anyway, so you think this is the end?
This is just the beginning.
okay we need to figure out the horse he's so hungry but i
don't know what to feed him
or do i feed the horse oh shit here we go again
he's like hungry but i don't know what he was
the cheese but then how would i get the knife though I
wonder if I have to choose the between the cheese or between
the dog or the pot, uh, the horse.
No, right?
Okay, pre-clean.
I'm pre-firing.
Okay.
Baseball the knife?
I'll try.
I don't know if I can.
Yeah, it doesn't baseball it.
No, it doesn't do that.
I don't know.
Because I need the knife to access the...
Uh...
Alright.
Give me, give me.
Ah, shit.
Whoops.
Maybe it'll trigger it.
Because I have a gun.
Which means that...
Whoops.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm gonna do it here.
Oh, oh, whoa, what the fuck?
Yes, give me a sec.
The cat's not there yet.
No!
No, no, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no, wait.
It's so cute.
I'm trying to swear to the cat.
No, I already did the sponge.
Oh my god, I made it just in time.
I made it just in time.
Surely the sister is gonna be fine.
Surely the sister is gonna be...
Sister, sister, sister, sister, sister.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, you're safe!
Oh, God!
I made it.
I made it, guys.
That was close.
Oh.
Clowns like, come here.
Here's the photo.
I don't know what to do with this, with the clown.
Wait.
Whoa!
Nope!
Oh.
I didn't ring it in time.
I didn't ring it and tap.
These are all...
Oh, that's cool.
I woke up so late.
Was that really him?
It couldn't be.
He's dead.
I spent so much time trying to make him proud, but he barely
ever noticed me.
His body fell all over.
Almost looked like he was smiling at me.
What do I do with the snail?
Alright, time, guys.
It's time.
I'm gonna need...
It's time, guys.
It's backseeding time.
What am I missing in this loop?
What am I missing?
I don't know.
Okay.
I need to do something.
Can you give the horse the pie?
But that won't be able to get the bullets, though.
Okay.
I can get the anvil?
Call a pizza?
Throw the above the dog to get anvil.
Oh.
Okay.
What do I do with an anvil?
Wouldn't I kill the dog?
No!
Why did I...
I...
He ate the pie.
I was so...
She was so...
I was...
I was so hungry.
I ate... I deserved that.
I ate it in front of the starving dog.
The dog was awesome.
So hungry and I ate it in front of him.
Hey.
When is it my turn to eat the pie?
The greed.
All right.
Just for the love of the game.
Oh my god, someone needs to potty train this cat.
Okay.
Then I killed the dog, though.
You want me to kill the dog?
Dog?
Ah, fuck, okay!
I guess I'll kill the dog.
Okay.
Well, it doesn't matter anyway because I killed the dog.
That's just that.
He didn't deserve it Oh shit Bathroom Bathroom I ate the pie
And then I kill him
Not only did I ate the pie in front of the starving dog I
had to kill him too!
Okay.
No!
I was trying to slip on it.
Well at least I got this.
You ate his pie and you killed him.
That's so fucked up, Doki.
I didn't mean to!
I think I would be able to grab this cheese, but up
i just mean that death is imminent everything you can get
out of this
maybe because i saved someone that's why
oh what if i
it will kill her here it might be safer the backyard's my my
pvp zone nice all right call for pizza i don't think there
is a phone for me to call for pizza guys
all right oh there's no phone anywhere what do i do with
tabby all right or nice yeah all right what do i do with my
snail there is next to the basement all right we'll call the
call for pizza Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I can.
Guys, what's the number for pizza?
Nine.
One, one.
That one, one?
What's your emergency?
Um, is anyone you know we're really busy over here?
I swear there's another...
I might...
Oh, I guess I just don't know how to talk anymore.
Oh, oh.
Whoa.
What the fuck is for pizza?
How do I know what number to call?
Oh, I forgot to get the bell.
Yeah.
Guys, it's never boobs, and you know that.
Oh, oh, I guess when the clown beckons, he'll, like, kidnap
me or something.
Oh, maybe dad will come up here and then...
Oh, he's coming.
Wait, are these the numbers?
You see that?
a four daddy's home all right if he kills us at least
okay my i i didn't realize my sister was on on the enemy
team as well i
yeah so apparently
Apparently my sister is also against me
Apparently it's PvP, PvP Top 10 anime betrayals I thought we
were a team, bro I thought we were on a fucking team
Okay, pie.
Wash dishes.
Clean pee.
Don't eat the pie, Doki.
Wait, is it?
Oh, Octo Pizza.
You want some pizza or what?
Hand on tight?
We got pizza cup.
Oh my god, we got pizza.
We got pizza and pie.
Oh my god.
okay we got pizza and pie pizza and pie
okay that means i don't have to kill the dog we save
everyone
give me the bell give me the bell all right who is my oh the
who is my about uh up the game yes cyber thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you We can save everyone!
Not the rat, though.
Fuck the rat.
Or my neighbor, though.
Only kids.
Okay.
Oh, we got that.
And then...
Where's the pizza coming?
I didn't realize I can...
Oh my god, I can pick this up.
What the fuck am I gonna do with that?
Okay.
What the fuck am I gonna do in Anvil?
What am I gonna do with this?
I'm just gonna drop it.
Fuck yeah, I don't know.
When's pizza come in?
Oh my god, where the fuck's my pizza?
Oh my god, the knife.
Whoops.
Oh, I thought the fridge was gonna fucking kill me there.
Alright, we got the knife.
Okay.
Where's my pizza?
Hello?
Oh, this is...
Oh, my God.
No!
I got fucking after it partied.
It was a trap.
I just wanted my pizza.
I can't believe I got baited.
Okay.
Oh my god, and it's looping.
Another loop.
We just keep looping.
The endless loop.
Okay.
Pizza, pizza, pizza.
Okay, you want...
Yes, I want pizza.
Please, I want to give the tourists a pizza.
Oh, please, my sister might be okay.
Okay, he hasn't peed yet.
He hasn't peed yet.
Okay.
All right.
And then pie will be done.
Pie's not done.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we don't need to save the mouse.
The mouse is not that important.
Pizza, pizza, pizza.
Okay, I have to call the pizza at the beginning.
Oh, please, please, please.
The cat don't move.
Nice.
We got pizza.
We can save everyone.
Okay, we have the call in the beginning?
Or...
Oh, come on.
Oh, my God!
Oh, please!
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm fucking...
Okay.
My cat's okay.
Oh, my sister's dead, though.
My sister's dead.
I got...
Oh, my...
My sister's dead.
Alright.
It's fun.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
My sister's definitely dead.
It's too late.
But at least we'll know where the horse is.
At least we know how to feed the horse.
Guys.
There you go.
Oh my, I just see entire pizza by myself.
The gluttony.
Okay.
What do I do now?
Very cute.
Toy, good thing I could peel for him.
Can't get rid of me that easily.
Over and over, we move to some squatted new spot, and then
some youngsters start making a mess.
That file is a terrible thing.
An atrocious conflagration.
I do think.
It all started with a swift kick to an oil lamp.
Oh, is that what the was for is to get in the basement.
How do I have enough?
How do I have enough time for all of this?
How do I have enough time for, oh my god, and now my, oh, my
scurion hasn't inflated yet.
Okay, maybe if I did not, okay.
Here I go.
Maybe don't miss your throne, Toki.
Okay, I just gotta start stabbing.
Okay.
Oh.
Alright.
Okay.
Here I go.
It must be the shotgun, but I did not get the bullets.
Boop.
Oh my god.
how do i know
oh and then i can save my aunt here
okay so oh the numbers oh daddy's here oh it was the numbers
on the walls i only know one of them it was four
four five
How did he get here so fast?
How did he get here so?
Oh my god.
Welcome back to another day.
Another beautiful day.
There's no way I can save it in time.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god, I forgot to grab.
I forgot to grab the baseball.
Okay, scrubby scrub scrub scrub.
Just don't miss.
Just don't.
I just don't miss.
Alright.
Just don't miss.
It's just that easy.
Just maybe if I...
Just pee pee!
Okay.
Meow.
Alright.
the pie pizza pizza pizza pizza oh
no oh no I just gotta play the perfect game 30 minutes or
less or the pizza's free I
should hit it yeah guys guys I did it I did it I did it
The B-spot, God, the B-spot, D-spot!
I D-spot the pizza!
It's over.
It's already over.
I don't even have the anvil.
The B-spot, D-spot!
Maybe...
come back
I got the knife though I got I got the knife though I know
matter what he does it's a canon event
I don't know what to do with this though
Rest in peace Mass I don't know I don't know
Check for the code now.
We'll find the code, I guess.
We have four.
Four is here.
Four.
Is there any numbers here?
Okay.
I don't think I've seen another number, though.
That's the thing.
I've only found number four.
There's no numbers in the closet.
Okay.
But it's just...
Oh, every time.
You're not going to get me!
I'll get by the clown!
There we go.
That's right.
What?
Oh, shit.
Oh, look.
A new toy to play with.
Oh, my God.
I'm supposed to stab the clown!
Oh my god, not again!
Not again!
Oh my god!
Where is he going?
What's that do?
What does that do?
What?
Oh, it makes water!
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, oh, you're
so close.
No, I'm stuck here until I kill him.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Well, that's good to know.
You know?
We're stuck in eternal clowndom.
I think the worst part is...
It's like super tight the window.
Oh.
It's just blowing balloons.
What?
Oh.
Oh my god, is he faster?
oh my god this is my hell this is actually my hell oh my god
I'm stuck in eternal stabdom no
oh my god just gotta keep stabbing
What is this funky clown music?
Okay.
I'm okay with that.
Oh, he got him.
I got Mr. Fingers.
Oh, my God.
Round two.
Mr. Fingers is round two.
What is Mr. Fingers doing?
Mr. Fingers has phases.
He is the DVD logo.
Get me out of here.
Oh my god.
No, not again.
I don't want to get me out of here.
Why did I go into the clown TV?
Why?
Okay.
I think I...
I don't...
Why did he say I won't die to my...
They must take me out.
This must take me out.
Take me out of the clown.
Oh, thank God.
What a horrible nightmare.
My hyperbolic clown chamber.
What a fucking horrible nightmare I had.
Oh, I got...
Those...
I'm out.
Because I don't want to go back in there.
I don't want to go back in there.
Damn.
You'll have to beat the cloud one day.
I refuse!
Good.
pizza I can't believe it I found a fate worse than death the
clown room okay
because if I don't do the dishes she gets abducted or some
shit I don't know I don't make the rules she gets fucking
abducted which I've noticed there's There's no way the clown
is the true ending.
We can do this quick.
Pizza will still be there.
That's it.
Now I have no legs.
It's all a horrible dream.
I had to take myself out.
I go off of my own terms.
No arms and no legs.
It's too late.
If...
So we go again.
Oh.
Her own terms took her to the clown room.
Hyperbolic clown chamber.
Oh my god, pie, pie, pie.
Wait, what?
Did I really do everything that fast?
Because I was supposed to scrub the pee.
I was...
Oh my god, that's why it was so fast.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza, pizza,
pizza.
Give me that pizza.
Pie!
Okay, I got the pie.
Alright.
Here we go again.
There we go.
Give me bell.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Then I got the baseball.
And then...
Okay.
Boom!
Alright.
There we go.
And I flushed the toilet.
The rat lives.
We're making good time.
Alright.
I feel like nobody appreciates the things I do for this
family.
I'm zooming.
The stuff I do for this fucking family Alright Alright Okay
we all, the aunt dies I don't think I don't think I can save
the aunt I legitimately don't think I can save her
Alright Okay The things I do for love Run faster, Toki Just
keep running.
I'm just a little kid.
Oh my god.
Bitch.
There you go.
Oh, she's...
Oh.
You're too late.
How's that?
Okay, yep.
Onsted.
Okay, four.
is that not is that not it guys for oh there you go okay got
a gun okay and then i have a bullet
all right wait 415 that's the code okay i have a gun gun get
oh he's so hungry oh he's sleeping now that's cute Oh, shit.
Okay, we got a stabber.
I'll shoot her.
Don't worry, I have another bullet.
I have another bullet.
Guys, I have another bullet.
I had two.
I have two.
It's okay.
She's coming.
Daddy's coming.
Daddy's
coming.
Oh!
Daddy's home.
That's right.
Guess what I have for you.
Okay.
Sister, can you blow your...
Oh!
Okay!
Oh, I'm fucked!
Oh, rules for thee, rules for me, but not for thee, I see.
I see now.
I, whoa, all right.
Oh, so that doesn't work for him.
Oh, no, it's back to the backyard I go.
It doesn't.
Oh, no, not again.
What do you mean?
There's a bird over here!
There's a fucking...
Save me!
Are you holding in there?
Trust me, I know what it's like.
They took everything from me.
You've been through this before, right?
I'm working on something.
Just need time to sort it out.
Just keep going.
Keep surviving.
No matter what, I'll see you around.
Oh, you bitch.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Here we go, I guess.
Oh, the bear trap, the bear trap, the bear trap rules for
thee.
No!
Okay.
All right,
here we go.
Rules for thee, but not for me.
She got faded yet again.
Like, what do you do?
Get to the bell!
Scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub.
Guys, I don't think we're saving Deont.
I don't even know how to save Deont at this point.
Wait, I think, like, what if...
I get that first?
So I don't have to worry about that?
You really said 1v1v2.
up.
Thank you for the super chat ace there.
Thank you.
Okay.
I got that out of the way.
I have to be so fast.
I don't know if I can.
No!
That's right.
There you go.
Yummy, yummy.
What happens?
Oh, we saw what happens and we don't clean the cat peep.
Give me my baseball.
Well, it's like I played these games before.
The loop.
It never stops.
It just keeps going.
Okay.
Pizza, pizza, pizza.
No!
Oh my god.
I already fucked up the speed run.
Get that baseball here.
Okay, okay.
Pizza.
Oh my god.
Peep, peep, peep, peep!
Okay.
Peep gone.
Uh, pie.
It's over one digit's right.
Reset.
Yeah, reset the playthrough, Toki.
Oh my god, it's the pizza.
Okay, we got one hit.
The baseball skit.
You never love that ad.
You're never gonna save her, Timmel.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Timmel.
Guys, you don't understand.
And the baseball skiff is so high.
It's the baseball skiff.
It's one of the hardest skips in the speedrunning community.
I don't know if you guys know that.
Okay, just don't miss.
Yeah.
Don't!
Okay, sorry.
No, no, no, no, it's fine.
I'll move it a little bit.
And then...
I drop it here.
Oh god, that was close.
That was so close.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh, I made it just in time!
Okay.
Okay, I have one more, I have one more, I have one more
minute, I have one more minute.
Okay, all right.
No!
I had time for my...
I had to keep right...
Talking about...
It was right there.
It was right there!
And I decided to reset the trap.
I was like, you know, hey, guys, I want to see me do it
again.
I want to see me reset.
You want to see me do the anvil again?
Okay.
All right.
All right, we got that.
Hello.
Okay.
Calm down.
Here we go.
We have time.
Toki in the bear trap.
Okay.
We're making good time.
We're making good time, guys.
We got the pie.
We had to do this anyway for the pie.
Okay.
Right here.
What?
I'm just fumbling.
I'm just fumbling the fucking trap.
It's like freaking cryptidite.
The goddamn third trap.
Don't keep fleeing.
That should have hit.
That should have been a fucking hit.
It's a bug.
It was a frame.
Perfect.
We almost forgot the pizza.
We got an idea.
Oh, I thought Oh, now it hits Now it fucking hits Oh, it's
fine
It's fine It's fine Oh, it's fine Oh, it's fine
Oh, I'm out of I'm out of sequence
I'm so out of sequence right now Oh No!
No!
I was like, you must have the pie.
You...
I escaped.
I saw the pizza.
Like, no, you don't deserve the pizza.
The pizza's for the horse.
I...
It was right there.
I was like, no.
Pizza for horse.
Pie for dog.
As has always been.
You should have eaten the pie.
As society sees fit.
Oh my god.
I'm just...
The way God intended.
Pizza for a dog.
It's a pizza for a horse.
Pie for a dog.
It's the saddest quote.
As our ancestors have wanted
Anything else is blasphemy Okay
And then
Okay Okay Perfect
Perfect it Perfect it Okay we gotta Okay We gotta make sure
our sister doesn't fucking die.
All right.
Oh my god, the pizza.
The fucking pizza.
Pizza!
Is he still there?
Okay.
But how to save Aunt?
I still don't know how.
Oh my god, please.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, my god, Anvil!
Oh, goodbye, Auntie.
Goodbye.
Oh, she's dead.
She's dead.
I didn't see the weird...
This is the perfect ride.
The perfect ride that the horse can't see.
Oh, my God.
And as a loop, we're in the loop.
The loop doesn't...
Oh, we gotta get the base spot, fucking.
The loop's over.
The loop...
I'm taking myself out.
I'm already lost seconds.
Fucking bear trap.
It was already plus one second.
That was too many seconds.
Plus one second.
Because I forgot to grab the sponge right off the bat.
Oh my god.
Baseball.
Okay.
We got everything.
Pie.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
okay pizza all
right okay just log it up here just log it up here but i
think he grabbed the knife instantly here boom and then p
timed oh my god i got the system in i got it i got the
sequence
There's the pizza.
Okay, then pie.
Oh, my God.
What happened?
That fucked with me.
Wait.
Oh!
I did.
Wait.
Does he actually give me a speed boost?
Oh, my God.
He does.
I thought that.
I thought that was a...
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize I was speed the entire time.
Okay.
That's gonna help.
Plus, plus speed.
That was shave some seconds off of my speed run.
All right.
Okay.
Scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub.
Backwards run.
Now we're cooking.
Okay.
Keep going.
The movement.
All right.
Let's get.
P-time.
The P sequence.
All right.
Sponge.
We got that.
Okay, I
I'm gonna pee over here right back
The bear trap is the run killer the it's it's like it's so I
I need to find like the the perfect frame to stand on To
always guarantee the fucking bear.
Oh my god.
I need to get water.
Let me just say
Oh The fucking bear trap.
The fucking bear trap.
I need to find the perfect position so I can get the fucking
bear trap.
Maybe look where you're going next time.
I don't need sass from you still.
What's the speedrun term where I got everything mapped out?
It's just...
Whenever we're at the bear trap, it's the bear trap.
trap
yeah bear trap any person i have everything routed out it's
just the bear trap
hey oh yeah hello i like it when she says that hello
yeah come on anvil We got this.
I'm going to grab the knife now.
I have time to clean the pee and get the knife.
I'm that confident.
I cleaned up...
I cleaned up his pee 50 times.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Two steps.
It's two steps.
We're two steps ahead.
Oh my god.
I need to bring me Anvil.
Okay.
We don't need the bell.
The bell.
We don't need it.
Oh, you almost got me.
You almost got me.
Pizza, pizza.
pizza oh it's fine i still managed to grab the pizza
i'm so hungry
i don't know if it was a good pizza though i
I'm so...
I don't understand.
The pizza was so good, though.
She ate it in front of the horse.
Why did she like this?
It was so hungry.
The pizza was so...
Oh god, it smelled so good, guys.
The pizza smelled so good.
You waited so long for that pizza.
Punch, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That horse looked hungry, but how hungry, though.
That horse was definitely not as hungry as me.
So I'm thinking of a super chat, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, apparently I need the baseball.
Alright, we figured out the bear, we figured out the bear
route.
The bear route is success.
All right, go up.
All right, we're figuring out the route.
We don't need the bell.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Oh,
I don't know.
How do I see?
save it
okay oh my god we saved we saved it only took us five tries
my
gun got gun got
okay bullets oh my god maybe i do need the bell maybe i do
need it's fine it's fine
all right now what is it time
Oh my god, the rat is, he's so hungry.
Fight the cloud!
I am not fighting the cloud.
I'm ready.
Ow.
It's cloud.
Die.
Toki, fight the cloud.
Fine!
You put these- that's fine.
Fine.
Get over here.
Oh, no, my staff!
That's fine.
I got the gun.
Yeah.
My generational bubble.
Oh.
Does it keep my ammo?
Well, we're about to...
Oh, you know what?
I'm going to use up all my ammo and see.
Okay, it does.
It does, guys.
That's good.
It keeps up all...
It keeps all my ammo if I lose this.
Alright, that's good.
I wanted to die.
I wanted to die, guys.
Guys, we wanted this to happen so I could tell, I needed to
know if I keep my ammo.
What the fuck is this baby?
Who is he?
I wish I had my snail.
I wish I had my snail, guys.
I do.
Oh my god, I wish I had my stealth.
No!
Okay, back to normal.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
No, are you kidding me?
What is the range?
okay
oh the range was so bullshit oh if only you had the snail it
was
that was my bad ah so fast
that's good I can get free stabs here.
Okay.
No!
Oh, I was so greedy.
I was so greedy.
That one I got too greedy for.
I got too greedy on that one.
I figured it out, though.
I figured out the pattern.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Oh my god.
It's a fighting game now.
I keep poking him.
Why
is he fucking...
He fucking walks so far!
...
oh oh my god oh my god
mr.
fingers oh my god what's that okay all right oh
the bullets don't transfer the bullets don't transfer
Oh, let's don't transfer!
Oh, I'm so scared.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, I don't have energy.
Oh, God, that was so scary.
Bro, wait, he fucking flies away.
Okay, I got three stabs in.
I'm not risking too many stabs in.
I'm looking at the shout, yeah, that's what I'm looking at.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to be too cocky here.
I'm not going to chase.
Oh my god, he did a huge turn.
He's doing it.
Is that the last face?
Oh my god.
I got the baby.
And goodbye, baby.
Guys, I don't have the bullets to say to kill.
The lights cut out and the crowd goes silent.
A deflated balloon sighs across the floor And the cameras
turn off The show is finally over You reach for the remote
And change the channel Did I do it?
Oh my god Wait, where's my family?
Save Susie Wait, where's my Wait, my sister and my My
Where's my family?
Hey, the horse is here.
The horse and the dog's here.
Horse is family now.
I guess...
The animals are your family now.
We did it.
Yay!
And Pete, the horse is here not even the cat oh lucky me
hello tabby was that supposed to happen I thought her
contract wasn't up yet she's not gonna be happy about that
you really think you're accomplishing something don't you
don't you realize by how now how pointless this is it never
ends happy ending Yay!
Why not?
I don't understand.
Did I not beat...
How did I not beat the cycle?
Who is that?
Lois would tell...
Lois?
Lois would tell a story about Majesty, how they were
inseparable, close-ass sister, After Majesty died, Lois
couldn't part with her.
She's family.
After she bit my head off, I could see tears shroom down her
face.
Mom and dad used to be put on Susie's circus before it.
Used to put on Susie's circus before bed.
I never liked it.
I thought it was just a stupid kid show.
It was strange, though.
It never went off the air.
Even after everyone stopped watching.
Well, I guess, I guess Horse is family, guys.
I don't know.
How do you even get true ending?
Guys, how do you even...
How do you even get the true ending, though?
Apparently the spider does...
What?
Oh, that's... Wait.
Oh.
Oh, what?
That's new.
Oh, don't make me fight the clown again.
Don't make me fight the club.
We figured it out, though.
Oh, so the endings do change the runs.
We're breaking the cycle little by little, yeah.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Was I too still?
Oh, it's because I got distracted.
I got distracted earlier.
It's fine.
fine oh no oh no don't know we save the sister from cat pee
no okay um well
you know the drill you know what let's see what the base but
oh we don't even have a base but you know what guys Oh, it's
too late.
Already fucked up the run.
Just take me.
No, it's too late.
We lost time.
We already lost time.
Please still.
You're messing up my speed run.
extra plus what dialogue
okay okay hi
don't know oh no please let me grab it okay we got the we
got
it okay eight eight eight eight eight eight perfect honestly
that is a great pizza number hello
Going up.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're keeping time.
Time is good.
Time is money.
Boom.
Grab knife.
Keep going up.
Ah, shit.
No, no, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, it's okay.
Sister safe.
okay do not eat the pie do not eat the pie do not eat the
pie no matter what happens do not eat the pie
okay baseball guy baseball get give me bell give me oh what
the hell doesn't matter bell no matter bell no matter
yeah all right Oh my god.
Bathroom flush.
Okay, here we go.
We're doing no bell run.
No bell run.
Snap!
Oh fuck, oh fuck.
Oh.
Hey pizza.
Pizza pizza.
Anvil.
Any percent?
No bell.
What?
Don't!
You don't need to take me.
She was like, what the fuck's going on?
I'm like, I'm on a clock right now.
You're fine.
You're safe.
It shows up.
Throw his ball.
No leaves.
What do I do now?
Now what?
What the fuck do I do?
Oh fuck!
Okay, maybe I need belt.
I refuse this to elaborate.
Ah,
yes.
The night throwing shadow sequence.
Because maybe we need Belle.
Oh, fuck.
Maybe Belle is needed.
I mean, you didn't die.
I don't even die.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
They scrub scrub scrub scrub scrub
All right, I can't believe you let him 360 nose cope you How
was I supposed to know this never came up
The fucking knife shadow never came up in any of my routes
Okay It's fine routes now perfectly we're gonna break the
cycle
oh guys the cycle will be oh what did i do pie it was the
pie it wasn't in the script
yeah give me okay we got the bell we got the bell we have
the bell now
all right we got that and then we grab Oh, where did I put
the anvil?
Oh, pizza.
Oh, it's pizza first.
It's pizza.
Put the anvil up top already.
Okay, and then we flush the toilet.
Alright.
And then we bring the anvil in.
Oh, we lost some time there.
Okay.
Alright.
We're almost there.
Oh, please live okay boom there you go refuses to elaborate
leaves got it good all right all right all
right I was an ambush where he was just to elaborate and
then I keep police.
How was I supposed to know?
It was the second guy.
The fastest knife in the West.
That's actually crazy.
Coming downtown.
It was still a fucking knife.
Okay.
Oh my god, take me out of this loop.
Creepy!
The sequence is getting too complex.
Alright.
Dodge Tokey!
Why won't she dodge?
She has her air Here, pot is hot.
Oh, no, she's in here.
Okay.
All right.
Grab the pizza.
Pizza get.
Okay.
I grabbed the pie.
Oh, we're behind in our sequences.
We're a little behind.
Give me the bell.
Give me the bell give me the bell
All right.
Oh, we're a little behind now.
We're a little behind.
Oh, this is bad
Okay, flush toilet flush the toilet.
Oh, the on my die here because I'm a little behind
Yeah Don't kill me.
Please don't bite me.
Oh please aunt just live three more seconds i have a giant
apple
there refuse to elaborate leaves
i swear to god i swear to god if he spawns in i'm looking at
all directions now okay hi auntie bye auntie Where do I go?
Where do I... Where do I go?
It's so evil.
Ah, yes.
The good old spike in the carpet trick.
The good...
Ha, the oldest trick in the book.
Children never expected.
Look at the memory!
The memory single time!
Oh, she'll never expect to happen again!
Just avoid the carpet.
Good, I'm such a timeless gag.
There's no way she'll expect it a second time.
Oh,
the spider doesn't spawn in yet.
When does he spawn in?
Throw me the thumb.
I dodged the knife, man.
I dodged.
I thought I was in the clear.
This is it.
This is the run.
Oh, I hope you're happy.
I hope you're having a good time dancing there.
Oh, spider after auntie.
I don't know what the spider does, but apparently gives me a
buff.
Oh my god, I forgot pies later.
I'm going to check if hair spawns in here.
Oh my god, hair doesn't spawn in yet.
Oh, I lost time.
Oh no, I'm out of sequence order.
I'm out of sequence order right now.
Run failed.
Bear trap yourself now.
The bear trap I go.
Okay, this is the run.
This is the run.
We figured it out.
We figured it in a loop.
We figured out how to beat the loop.
The loop ends now.
Alright.
The run killer truly is.
Alright, here we go.
Aloo, alo, alo, alo!
Okay.
Keep going.
We keep going.
Alright.
Keep bringing this up.
Yeah.
Alright, now go grab the pizza.
It's a pizza.
And then...
We go grab the pie?
Pie pie.
Okay, we gotta make sure we don't accidentally eat the
pizza.
Yeah.
There you go.
Mastered it.
Give me the bell.
Y'all, we don't need bell.
Any percent, no bell.
We're not gonna regret this choice that we made.
No regrets.
No regrets, guys.
Let's...
There you go.
Here you
go.
Fall.
Fierces to elaborate!
Just in case, just in case, just in case, you know, just in
case, just in case, you know, just, just just in case, I
know I said I'm not gonna worry about it, but just in case,
just in case, just in case something does happen.
Okay, we saved everybody.
We saved everyone.
We just wait.
We have gun now.
We wait.
Okay.
Oh, spider.
Spider, you're so right.
I don't think I was supposed to step on him.
Whoops.
Uh...
Um...
Oh...
Yeah, I see the holes.
It's very dark, so it's like a little scary, though.
It's not, but I want to go downstairs and fight him.
Like, shoot him in the hallway.
My plan is to shoot him in the hallway.
I'm scared, guys.
You don't fight him?
What do I do?
I don't fight him.
Oh?
I did it?
I did it.
Oh!
I saved...
He was mad because I got everybody killed!
The overwhelming dread.
This is Bates.
A sense of calm.
radiates through the house.
Relief watches over you.
See, guys, killing the spider was all right.
You hold on to it as long as you can.
spider lives don't matter.
Wait, the horse joins the family!
We did it!
Everybody lives!
Don't kill the spider!
Oh my god.
Family tonight.
Only the spider is missing.
Finally.
We got the true ending.
Is there...
I don't know if this is true ending, but we got the good
ending.
To make you proud, Dad.
And she casually slips the loaded gun into her pocket oh
yeah i got it i'm like i'm ready i'm so ready hello lucky me
hello tabby oh how nice you saved almost everyone was it the
spider was it the spider is it because i didn't save the
spider It's nice to have a family isn't it?
I can't really You just don't stop do you not like you did
it all on your own though Spider Well, keep at it.
Guess it's your life to wait And never oh, it's a rat trap I
didn't realize rat lies matter apparently wasn't even the
spider it was the rat that i let die we did it guys we saved
everyone i like this i like to call that a ggs i we did it
we still it's not even the spider in the hierarchy the rat
is it's a rat lies matter more than spider lies everyone
that lived mattered oh wait before we guys you know just
just like just like old times guys let's do one more run for
old times sake as a throwback to your very first as a
throwback to your very first uh time playing house.
I wonder if there's a girl in the backyard.
Wait, I shall grab, uh, I'll grab my snow.
It felt so nice to have everyone together.
It felt like a dream come true, but we know better now.
None of it is real.
What do you mean it was all a true?
No, no, it was real, see?
It's nice to pretend that everything was normal, that my
family wasn't dead, and I wasn't trapped in this nightmare.
It was nice to feel happy, and then...
And then I woke up again.
Just let go of time.
I'm going to see.
Oh.
Oh, it's starting to break, though.
See that?
It broke again.
Let's see.
I'm going to see the girls at the backyard.
There's the butterfly.
We have the girl.
No, she's not hearing.
Oh, wait.
Do I see that?
She is here.
Hey, I've been putting it out together.
I saw so much bigger than you were.
me we're just a small piece in the game disposable there's
been other kids some even younger than us and uh talk to any
toilets lately good don't continue to kill like that it
changes you anyway you know what to do give them what they
want i just need a little more time i'll see you around all
right oh my god get back on here All right.
Okay, the rat's not even our rat.
Do you guys want to see my sister die?
Just like old times.
Half in any second.
I...
No!
Don't get cleaned up!
Oh, I didn't even bring the sponge.
I didn't...
Oh, it's gonna be so fucked up.
I don't even know what the...
All we knew was that we saw her dead underneath.
Oh, shit.
Wow.
I wish someone cleaned the cat, Pete.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Oh my god
See it would have been It would have been I think you guys
would have called me a witch But what happened in the first
game Was I randomly entered the room But before I entered
the room I was like hey guys I want to see my sister die And
then a fucking piano fell on her The exact moment I said
that If it had happened the second time you have been like
burn the witch twice in a row now that's weird now if that
happened twice in a row see now you know I'm not a witch
because I didn't know when that was gonna happen that first
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you some of the
fatalities in the game are more brutal than if yeah I know
it's crazy like in the first game it's just all pixel art so
I lost my Yeah.
I ran out of mana.
It's just, you know.
I just, I don't know.
I just don't have it.
I guess I just, I'm just rusty.
I'm just rusty, I guess.
Hey, guys.
That was a fun game.
It was fun going, tracking out the sequel.
Yeah, I chickened out.
Oh my gosh, it's like, oh, wow, you took chicken out.
It actually just closes the game.
That was really fun though.
I guess I don't want to do another.
I don't want to do another run I'm not strong enough to do
another I can't I can't I'm scared.
I'm I can't I don't think I'm strong enough to get the true
ending
Why get the best ending say okay, what do I have to do to
get the best ending?
traps is all right what do i have to do to get the best
ending tell me the sequence tell me the sequence it's just a
rat right it's just a rat is it the rat is the rat isn't it
it oh it's a oh my god five one last run one last run for
the ride we're not the spider can die
here you go
bear trap save the rat save the world one last run one last
job what the clock we can do this i believe
the spider has to live i'm pretty sure the spider life does
not matter i think we're supposed to kill the spiders so the
rat can live
god damn it fine one last job Guess I'm coming out of
retirement, boys.
It's the rat run.
Wake up, wakey-wakey.
Rat any percent.
Get in here.
Okay.
Baseball.
Alright.
We have everything memorized.
We have frame perfect sequence now.
We're gonna do the perfect run.
Like Mario.
Oh my god.
That added point.
Oh no.
Runs dead, Toki.
It's time.
Go to the bear trap.
You've added 0.5 seconds.
To it from the phone call.
Run dead.
It's time the bear trap calls for you.
One second lost.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
It's the.
I forgot.
Oh.
Fuck, oh fuck now!
It's already over.
I forgot to trap yourself.
I I missed my pick so perfect
I forgot to carry the the anvil Every every step counts
every second counts There you go all right
yeah i'm gonna scrubby dub dub scrubby dub dub
eight eight eight eight eight eight eight are you oh are you
okay all right get that anvil there
that's up that my sister asked me to do the dishes when i'm
literally like i have an amputated hand i'm literally
one-armed scrub scrub scrub grab the pizza later it's fine
and grab the pizza later
oh my god i gotta make sure i
okay grab the baseball bell bell we don't need bell bell no
percent No bell and people, any percent.
We don't need a bell.
It's fine.
The ant lives.
The ant will be alive.
The ant's going to be alive.
Don't worry.
The ant's gonna be alive.
The ant will be alive.
The ant lives.
It's okay.
alive.
She's alive.
Okay.
Not everyone is alive.
We did it.
Wait, did I kill him?
Where's the spider?
See, everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay.
Watch this.
there you go
no knife no knife everything is okay rat lives everyone
lives we already saved the baby baby's been saved all right
that's why I'm capping the stairs just in case babies
already been saved we don't have to save baby again
saved okay
save everyone save everyone I got the achievement I did it
tabby I did it I did it I did it
there you go we saved everyone I told you I didn't even kill
the spider look at that we got it don't we want to dread
dissipates a sense of calm radiates through the house relief
washes over you warm you hold on to as long as you can there
we go look look the rat look see I told you no one cares
about the fucking spider the rat everyone is alive Everyone
that matters is alive.
Everyone is here.
Now it's time for true ending.
Oh, it's you again.
Wow, aren't you a little overachiever?
Couldn't do it on your first try, though.
The bear trap.
The goddamn bear trap.
I'll make sure to send your prize or something.
You just don't stop, do you?
you did it all on your own, though.
Well, keep at it, I guess.
It's your life to waste.
It never ends.
Gosh, she's such an auntie.
She's just a hater.
Um, I did it.
What do you mean, call it out?
Um, all me?
Oh, is there more?
Now, what do we do?
I'm gonna grab the sponge just in case I don't trust myself.
Ben's girl?
Hit the claw?
How do I hit the claw?
Oh.
I can't hit it.
Not over.
What do you mean it's not over?
I saved everyone!
What else do you want from me?
I have to get everyone...
Okay, that's pretty easy, though.
Okay.
Okay, we already talked to...
Wait, do I have to die too?
Wait, okay, but like... Oh shit, snubby.
Wait, including my snail?
Do I have to kill my snail too?
Oh, I have to stab everybody?
Wait, do I have to kill them myself or...
Do I have to kill them myself or um...
Wait, how do I kill the horse?
Me?
So, like, they can't die from the environment.
Wait, okay.
How do I kill the horse?
Oh, God!
How the fuck am I gonna get the bullets, though?
I'm, like, wondering how I'm gonna kill the cat.
Well, I guess I'll have, like, one...
Oh.
Get pizza and then stab.
Okay.
Cat with anvil.
I killed a cat with the anvil.
I got timed that perfectly.
Oh, I can just squish him.
Never mind.
Shit, I'm taking...
Toki.
I'm just playing the game.
I'm just playing the game, guys.
Okay.
Hello.
I mean, it's a...
I guess a dog doesn't go up.
All right.
I'll grab the knife first.
I stabbed the pizza guy, too, yeah.
All right, I'm gonna grab the knife and I'll just start
stabbing, I guess.
All right.
all right oh i forgot
okay i got
all right two down
uh hello thank you oh shit goodbye all right i never liked
you
Oh, I fucked that up.
I don't think he'll like.
He'll be fine with a burnt.
That'll be fine.
Alright.
Okay, where's the cat?
Here we go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he definitely did not like that.
How the fuck do I kill the dog now?
I have to shoot the dog.
I guess
It's Christ Oh my god Oh shit Oh shit, oh I'm sorry
Are you the Oh shit, oh shit, my crimes Ah fuck
Alright, we gotta find the rat
I'm so close I had to get this Ah, the rat's just like,
yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
But you see, good job, Toki.
Oh, I forgot to kill my snail.
Good job, Toki.
Save the rat.
You know what?
I could grab the snail and I'll crush him with the anvil
later.
I got the plan.
You didn't kill the spider.
Yeah, I'll carry the snail and then kill him later.
That's the plan.
That is fucking brutal, though.
I will say it.
Alright.
What is this game even about?
I'm just trapped in a loop, guys.
This is an endless loop.
Yes.
Alright, we got this out of the way.
Stop.
This doesn't matter.
I don't have to clean any cat pee anymore.
Stop.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, uh...
I need...
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, it's like crazy.
No!
Oh no!
Alright.
I got the gun early.
Oh shit, okay.
No!
Guys.
And apparently I did need the clean the cat bee.
The consequences of my own actions.
Okay, guys.
Maybe I should have cleaned the cat bee.
Maybe it was in my hubris karma.
If only someone cleaned the cat bee.
The pig is chick.
Okay.
Drum it up.
Past Doki's truck again.
I was like, don't worry, guys.
We don't need to clean the cat feet.
Alright.
Okay.
The thing is, I need to figure out where the fuck the rat
is.
Okay, the rat will be...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, the pie's done.
I'm just gonna grab the pie now.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Almost forgot.
Alright.
There you go.
Just think I didn't forget.
Hey.
Stop.
Alright.
Thank god I didn't forget guys.
Yeah.
Oh I can't even- oh I- oh there we go.
All right, we got the spotter.
Nobody lives.
Stab.
All right.
Now it's time to wait for the rat.
Rat, where are you?
Where's the rat?
It's like a Tom and Jerry's kit.
here for you rat all right
okay okay okay we have to wait we have to wait for the rat
oh the dog the dog did i did i stab did i stab the dog i
don't remember but you're right
okay there we go
The fucking oldest trick in the book The fucking call is the
carpet Oh This actually has to be the hardest
The carpet I got him The spear The spear is through the
carpet The good old carpet sphere i
don't think this is the easiest run because the more you
kill the more they fuck with the environment they
like there's like more obstacles
yeah it has to be most difficult
just because they're like everywhere
i know maybe i'll kill the cat first
all right and i'll kill them
all right
all right here we go you know what okay i'll save her life
and then i'll just stab her here so at least i'll have the
kitchen you know
so my plan oh she's not here yet Wait, where is she?
Oh, I killed her too fast.
Alright, I'll kill her here.
Wait, do I have pie?
There you go.
Oh, I don't have...
I knew I forgot something.
I should have got the gun and shot the dog.
I thought I'd be faster.
I thought...
I legitimately thought I'd be...
I'll be like, I'm so fast.
I...
all right we got the route though i thought i'll be faster
than the dog
all i want to do is stab
i knew i forgot something in the route i was like i got
everything planned out perfectly except for the dog it was
almost perfect
All right, here we go.
I got it.
I see it.
I see the vision now.
I see it now, guys.
I see it.
I figured it out.
I see the vision in this round.
This one right here.
This one.
I see.
I figured it out right here.
Right here.
I wonder if it has any newer.
Oh, look, they drew everybody else.
Okay.
I don't think I have to stab Bell Guy, right?
Do I have to stab Bell Guy?
Wait, that's a good question.
I forgot about Bell Guy.
Does anyone know if I have to stab Bell Guy?
I forgot about him.
Do it just in case.
Everyone, dokey.
Oh,
you don't need...
Alright.
No, okay.
Because it's good to know.
That's actually good to know if I have to stab him.
I'll squish the cat first.
Actually...
At least I can grab the pie before anything happens.
Alright, speed run time.
And then I got...
Let me clean this real quick.
Scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, scrub, just in case.
Okay.
Thank you for the pizza.
Oh, yeah.
I gotta...
Let me just throw this.
Oh, fucking hell.
Okay, there we go.
Come on.
It's squished.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
I squashed a cockroach.
It's almost the same.
Okay.
all
right there we go all right we do
oh auntie goodbye auntie
there you go it
goes through here oh my god oh my
god Fuck, I'm trying to stack.
I can't- oh no!
The anvil is with the odds!
I fucked up!
Okay, we can make it.
Where's the rat?
It should- he should rotate here, right?
Yeah
No That's my king rat Get over here
Okay, okay, we figured it out and I went to anvil the snail
Ah, yes
Oh god, oh this is so bad.
This is so bad for me.
After all this time...
I can't carbon.
We were so calm.
I forgot about...
I got him.
I can't carbon.
is there.
The goddamn card, the oldest drink in the book.
It works every time.
Right at the end.
Oh, that just...
I had three people chasing me.
Can't believe you fell for it again.
I'm not gonna kill her right off the bat.
I'm gonna grab this first, too.
So I don't burn it.
Okay.
Alright.
You gotta clean this up.
Clean!
Aside from the guy, we got the squish.
Pick up the...
Pick it up.
There we go.
Not letting you eat that.
Where am I bringing the anvil?
So I can stab her in here.
There we go.
That's why.
That's why I don't need the gun.
Stop!
Oh my god!
I forgot
about this lucky loop.
Oh please.
Please get me out of this loop.
That's rough, buddy.
The ride never ends.
I just want to let me kill them Just all I want to do is
stab I don't ask for much Just let me stab Oh
no Oh no I don't understand It's like I'm a I don't know how
that makes me a bad person Why is everyone trying to stop me
from fucking stabbing everyone?
I don't understand.
Is that too much to ask for?
A little stab or two?
That's it.
I'm gonna have to stab her here.
I'm gonna grab that.
I don't care.
I'm gonna kill the cat downstairs and hope to God I slip.
I'll clean this first.
Alright.
It's just...
All right, we're gonna have to wait.
All right, we're gonna have to kill Snebby here right now.
I don't care.
Oh my god.
People said I...
They said I can slip.
They lied!
I don't care.
Oh my god.
Why did I bring the anvil here?
I don't know.
know all I need to do is stab
okay maybe oh my god oh my god
there you go
oh this is bad this is bad please don't get me please don't
get me
okay I got recharged so I can run
all right It's just a waiting game.
It's just you.
It's just it's just no not the cat.
No God a fucking harness And he shows up He fucking shows up
as well He's like a fucking queer demon That's
why you can't wait
The fuck hits the rat!
It's a goddamn rat!
I want some just hanging.
The goddamn stupid fucking rat.
I need to kill the rat.
But he has to eat the cheese!
It's the worst part.
Alright.
I forgot to get the knife.
The goddamn knife.
Okay, I don't need the anvil anymore.
I just need to stab my sister.
Alright.
Oh my god.
the pizza guy and the pizza guy.
Oh, this is not it.
This is not the run.
Oh my god.
I forgot about the pie.
Bye, everyone.
It's down the big chat, myself.
There's so many things in this chat I have to do this and I
have to do that oh my the wonder the world no one it's just
who would have thought killing was so hard no wonder there's
not a lot of serial killers in the world it's too much work
why do all of that
it's just so too tedious you need like a checklist you think
like serial killers actually keep a time to remember to buy
this they must have like a little checklist of what to do
step-by-step progress it's just not worth the killing is
just not worth the effort really is it and the cleaning oh
my gosh why even murder at that point it
Okay, I gotta splat the cat first.
Let me splat cat.
And then me grab pie.
I know I don't need to, but I'm doing it for the sake.
For the sake of the game.
And then...
Alright, now throw the baseball.
Grab that killer.
Okay, well she's watching TV right now.
Oh my god, that's fine, that's fine.
She's watching TV right now.
Okay, there you go.
I might be able to kill the rat.
Yeah, I'm gonna do this.
Squish the rat.
Oh my gosh, she's still there.
Oh my god, where are you?
Oh.
Here we go.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait a minute.
It's just the dog!
Okay.
I have to tell Paul, too.
There's a dog!
I don't feel like hanging out right now, Tabby.
Oh, my God.
What do you mean I have to kill the doll?
I killed...
He hates me too much.
I killed him too many times.
It's okay.
He doesn't remember the sack this time.
It'll be fine.
Let's do this, yay!
Okay.
Okay, apparently I don't have to, I never had to wash the
dishes.
That saves me time.
I know!
Alright, we got this.
We got this!
We can do this!
We're so close!
Just need to kill the cat.
If I don't fuck myself over.
Alright.
We got this!
Nice.
I fucking live.
Just live.
Live!
No, it's okay.
The spiders don't matter.
The spider doesn't matter.
Oh, the pie.
The run is dead.
I forgot about the pie.
all right we shoot the dog
there you go
yeah all right
oh not the cat oh why did it no no i killed everyone i oh no
no no no
no where's the dog guys where's the dog i forgot about the
doll
no no I can't crush it I can't crush it
you're right oh my god I can't shoot it either maybe
he'll show up maybe he'll show up
oh my god I'm getting camped right now I'm getting camped
oh my god
Oh, everything wants to kill me.
Come on.
I'm a very good girl, Tabby.
Yeah?
Oh, thank you.
He's so proud of me.
Papa's so proud.
I live.
You're covered in blood.
A good ending that's in your hair and under your nails.
It drips from your fingertips into a puddle at your feet.
You look down and see your reflection, running back at you.
The house is dead silent as you sink into the floor.
Yay!
Good ending!
Papa's little cereal.
Yippee!
Right here.
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Thank god I didn't need to find the dog
Oh my god Chip off the old block Oh lucky me Hello tabby
Sure you didn't take you long before going home But sadly
get up I do enjoy watching you butcher your fam This is me
on the 200th loop I think I've been bloodier, though.
Why don't just give up already?
I feel like after a while, if we get into too many loops,
murder is the option at that point.
Like, what's going to happen?
We're just going to loop again.
It doesn't matter.
Do you really need me to say it again?
It never ends.
All right.
Pretty much.
We're just going to keep looping.
Oh, my God.
It's time.
You want to join us?
thing you don't like me or something.
Oh?
Is it time?
Is it true ending?
What's that?
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Just all sand.
Everywhere I go.
Oh.
I found it.
Thank God it wasn't that hard.
Wait, how do I have to go on the other side?
Are you serious?
I have to go on the other side.
They're like, nope.
The only way to access the ladder is this way.
I like how there's no lights.
Anywhere?
Where do I go?
At least there's no monsters here.
Thank God.
it has to be this way the other side is just oh there's
lights here I see the light oh hey who are you you don't
have an arm too well you're just like me uh hi
I'm just gonna stay here it's not so bad my name not like it
matters nobody remembering me anyway I'll remember you we
sat in your little drive, I can't get used to that.
I can still hear hails walking down the hall.
I feel strange to be free.
Mom will come home at midnight.
She always has a break in her purse.
Were you trapped too?
Go around the wardrobe, get the dog, dig up the heat, dodge
grandma.
I think I got used to the fear.
To the routine.
You met the girl, huh?
She's delusional.
She thinks she can stop them.
I can spend blood on you.
You killed me in your loop, didn't you?
I could never do it.
I can't just...
I want to be alone.
Okay.
I'm fine.
Fuck off, I guess.
I just wanted to hang out.
Is that everything in there?
Oh, there's another ladder.
It's a new ladder?
Oh!
Who's that?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going on?
That's, yeah, that's a big-ass feat.
I stepped on that.
For free?
Just hang out, just hang out there?
There's nothing over here.
I don't know.
I try to talk to him.
He won't talk to me.
Is there anything back here?
Oh, that's it.
Oh my god, I thought I thought I got all the endings and
they'll be nice to me.
But no, there's always more.
Yeah, I got that.
That should open something, right?
Maybe?
Oh yeah, there's this.
So maybe there's another thing here for me to open.
I clicked one of them, so there might be another one.
I didn't... I need a five.
Don't say, oh, it's so dark.
Is that something over there?
No.
I wonder if there is another one.
This is where the guy is.
Yeah.
I'll go down and see.
Maybe it's down here.
Oh my god, it's just so confusing.
It doesn't help that it's so dark, too.
I just don't know where to go.
I'll check it up again.
Maybe it's timed.
It could be timed, so I'm going to have to press it again.
Nope.
Was there more things for me to go?
I'll check it back.
I'll backtrack just in case.
Go back to the first area?
Maybe I walked too far.
Yeah.
put me back in the loop this is worse put me back put me
back in the loop take me back take me back I don't want to
be here anymore
what's this oh
my god there's six oh no what do you mean there's a sad
story
I have to find all six take me back take me back to the loop
but not really not really though not do not make me do this
all over yet okay it's like this way
okay got another one here what the fuck I can't even reach
it
Oh.
Oh, no.
No!
I didn't realize it was following me.
Do I have to do that again?
Do I have to do that all over again?
Oh, no.
Don't tell me that's the loop.
No!
Is that the rude sandstorm?
Super chat NST, take it, thank you.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, it's coming.
Man, it's coming.
I didn't mean it.
Don't put me back.
I wish I wish my snail was here.
I wish I didn't kill him so many times.
I wonder if there's anything...
Oh, above?
Wait, I passed one?
I can't tell.
And everything looks the same!
Oh my god, there's one over here.
Maybe I'll...
Does he destroy this?
It doesn't destroy it.
Oh no.
I don't even know where I am anymore!
Wait, this is...
where it all begins okay maybe this is worse than the loops
this actually might be worse
he's conveniently placed rocks surely there's one button
here surely
what the fuck is this why am I supposed to do with another
rock oh no come on
Please have mercy.
I'm so lost.
Let's put this here.
We'll leave this here.
I don't know.
There's another frog?
Where am I now?
God.
Why did I decide to do a true ending?
Why?
Why did I...
This is worse.
I'm in super hell now.
Why did I do this to myself?
This is worse.
This is significantly a lot worse.
What the fuck is going on?
now where am i oh that that guy absolutely does not look
friendly i'm gonna go talk oh my god oh my god please i'm in
supreme where am i where am i
That's a hand.
I'm gonna go back.
I'm sorry.
I can't help with you on this one.
Let's see.
You and I can't do this.
Now where am I?
Where did I go?
I thought this game...
I thought it was just buttons.
I thought this...
It was just buttons.
buttons
what?
go up?
okay, I'll go up.
this is hell for hell.
guys, I'm this close to just downloading somebody I'm this
close.
I'm this close.
I don't think we're gonna fucking 5-11 buttons.
guys
Okay, I'm up now.
Now where am I?
Where is this place?
What do I do here?
Where is my mini-map?
I'm just lost.
Oh, no, no.
Not the tornado.
Where's my...
Where's my ladder?
I don't do.
What do you mean put rock in hold?
Did you see me bring any rock with me?
We never...
What is this?
Yes!
Now there's crystals!
That's it.
Give
me a second.
Alright.
Give me a second, everybody.
What is this?
What?
How do you get there?
Okay.
How?
How do I even get there?
Oh my god.
Does anyone do it?
guys i'm trying very hard to figure this out but i've yet to
find anyone that's doing the desert right now
i haven't i don't see anyone i'm trying so hard to find the
desert ending And I, I found one ending, and I'm like, I
don't even, I've never even seen this before.
How do I get out of the desert?
Out to desert.
How?
How do you get out of the desert?
What, there's traps?
What?
What do you mean?
What is this?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I should have been getting the rocks.
And like, how do you navigate all of this?
How does anyone navigate this?
How is this possible?
How?
House 2 speedrun True ending Surely Surely someone has a
speedrun Of House 2 Surely someone I
can't find I can't find anyone Stuck in the desert like me
Surely I don't even know where a place all the rocks.
It's just a whole desert.
I don't even know where they are.
I didn't know.
I didn't know there was more to this.
Oh, no.
No, I chucked one of them in a random area.
Who told me to get true ending?
Who told me to do this?
to get through the desert unit horse with no name thank you
for the super chat crash thank you thank you oh my god is it
this this is this oh my god it's three hours long guys i
don't think i can watch three hours of guys oh my god the
true ending alone is two hours long oh my god
the true someone spent two hours on true ending alone wait a
little bro let's watch it does anyone have a no commentary
true and that's That's all I ask for.
That's all I ask.
No commentary, true ending.
More like, oh boy.
Oh boy.
Okay.
House 2.
Wait, who's next to me?
Did you guys hear that?
Is there someone here?
Did you guys, you guys heard that, right?
Someone follow me?
Oh, I swear to God, I heard someone.
I heard something next to me.
Well, I was trying to fucking find true ending.
Oh, my God.
will I ever get true ending all right let's see how long
this is gonna down take me to download let's see let's see
how long this will take me to download this three hour long
video let's
see all right download a YouTube video video guys guys step
one final rock all right one gigabyte one gigabyte right
here game in my let's see game in my veins true ending house
to house
too.
He doesn't do the complete playthrough.
He only does, it's only like, he doesn't show me the desert.
I need to see the desert.
I need to see somebody go through the fucking desert.
All right, let's see how long this is going to take me to
download, guys.
We're going to see how long this is going to take me to
download.
Okay, it's not bad.
20 seconds, guys thank god okay showed up to who was it who
did download this from show up to madly badass hero i he
went through the entire he went through it showed up to him
he did it showed a madly badass hero he powered through i
did it i did not i I did not power through.
Alright.
We're not gonna have...
Let's see.
I'll put a text out.
Shout out to him.
He powered through.
I did not.
I will not.
I will not power through.
We'll see it to the end.
I can't I'm not strong enough guys you notice that I am
absolutely not strong enough for this I
I I there are limits to the desert this was my limit this is
my limit I'm closing the game this is where I had to limit
myself All right, where is it?
There he is.
And I'm like, wow.
All right.
Okay, she's...
How is he here?
How is he?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
All right, at least he's narrating for us, too.
All right, how does he do this?
How does he do...
Oh my...
Turn up the volume.
What?
You don't want to hear me?
What do you mean can't hear manly?
You're hearing my commentary.
You're listening to me.
Alright, video...
the desert was too much oh my god
all right see he's in the desert i'm skipping some of this i
i don't know how long he's gonna be stuck in the guys this
video is two hours long i don't know how long he's gonna be
stuck in this fucking desert guys i you don't need to hear
him you know we just need to know how he did it we just need
to know how he did it we don't need to hear him i guys i
wish i could wait i Maybe I can.
Let me see if I can put in 2x speed.
How do you do it on here?
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
Okay, how does he do it?
All right, here we go.
Map by me!
You can die!
You can...
What is this?
You can't fight.
I Oh my god, he already got three he already got three.
Oh my god, he cuts parts out because of how long
What am I hearing?
I hear something about in the background.
There's no way what video is playing right now?
What video I closed oh my god, it's the trailer.
I'm hearing the fucking trailer.
That's what's playing right now non-stop i don't know i
don't know that's oh my god i don't know when the trailer
has been playing how long the trailer's been playing for it
for so that's what we've been hearing this entire time we've
been hearing the trailer this entire time in the background
i don't even know how long that's been playing for by the
way all right oh
my god how does he know where he's going there's the rocks
oh my god you could have he found the rocks oh my god it's
just sand is there so much sand
it's just sad oh my god this is two times speed by the way
speed where did he find this rock where did he what where
did he find that i don't even know maybe we need honestly
maybe we do can i go beyond 200 i can't i this is the best i
could do please put 4x speed oh my god what is this what the
I'm playing this via meat.
I downloaded this video.
Thank you, Madly Fazio, for going, for suffering through
this.
I, I thank you.
Shout out to, check him out.
I'll link his channel.
Like, I, there was no way I would fucking figure this out.
Even with your help, there was no way.
Who was it?
Who told me to do true ending?
Who the fuck told me to go through this hell?
This was actually super hell and he's cutting parts out.
We don't know how long he's been stuck here We don't know
because he doesn't stream this.
He does this like he edits these This is actually super hell
like He's cutting parts.
We don't know how long he's been trapped here.
We don't know He could have been fucking in this area for
five hours for all I know
It's a hell of in hell.
Bless his soul.
It all looks the same.
Everything looks the same.
Time loses.
I'm happy.
Put me back into the loop.
Put me back into the house.
He made a.
fucking map that's when you know it we saw that we saw that
we were like what the fuck was that today's a good day my oh
she finally win this the stubborn completionist power my
favorite horror let's play who hurt him who hurt this man
what people were completionists who hurt you guys honestly
what gives you the motivation to do this to yourself.
Ballotard, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, this is where we discovered the fucking diamond area.
Like we had to find rocks and then we had to find diamonds
and then we had to find the fucking switches.
Like, what?
I'm warning food.
Fuck, I'm warning sushi.
Wait, is it?
Oh, thank God I can still order sushi.
I'm gonna order sushi.
What do I eat today?
What do I, okay, I'm wondering.
What do I eat for lunch?
Look, another, uh, in another, uh, oh, I ate a sandwich.
I did.
I'm gonna order a sushi.
I'm a winner.
I'm winning right now.
I'm not doing this.
Oh my god.
This is two times speed, by the way.
This would have been so much slower.
At some point, I wish it was 4x speed.
This is so unvalid.
You want to sit there with me for three to four more hours
trying to figure out the desert.
You want me to figure this out.
He just dropped.
He's really good at this game.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You want me to do what he is doing at the normal speed.
I am doing this at 2x speed right now.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sarah, thank you for the super chat.
Poor game call house.
Why are you in this?
Guys, I'm starting to start skipping.
I don't know how long you're going to be trapped in here
for.
There's birds.
here oh my god he got the diamond does it loop though okay
sounds like Yoshi does he keep his rock
is the loop that is the raging thank you for the super chat
now I don't oh my god God, he lost his rocks and his
diamonds.
Oh, that would have broke me.
This would have 100% broke me.
Oh, my God.
And I assume if these get you, you also loot.
Oh, no.
cutting.
He has to cut.
Oh my god.
He has to cut because he had to do that.
He had to
find fire.
Oh my god.
Again.
That's terrible.
That's actually terrible.
That's so cruel.
Guys, they have to make sure the game was longer than two
hours.
Guys.
This was the two hour this is where they're like all right
we gotta make sure to pass the two hour mark we throw them
into the desert if they figure out the loops too easily we
throw them in the fucking desert
again unrefundable what do you even it's true ending it's
like a true ending
I'm gonna...
Okay.
Okay, we saw that.
Oh my god, he's still there.
He's still there.
He's still...
Everyone...
Does he get out?
He gets out of here!
He gets out here!
Right here!
Wait, how did he get there?
Well, I must imagine...
Oh my god Maybe like each of the switches gives you an
ending My sack, thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you Some play games Some play horror games I'm feeling
scared Some take on a challenge but this man Manly, he just
does it for the heck of it Thank you for the super chat
Sergeant, thank you, thank you
Mr. Broken Button Thank you for the super chat, thank you
Almost got you to do two true endings back to back.
Me?
Bop.
Bye.
How did he get that?
Oh.
Oh, he won't shoot.
Oh, he woke up.
Oh, my God.
I'm back in the loop.
After I do that, I
Is it like...
He knows this isn't my val- He knows this is stolen val-
Can he do it?
What is he doing?
There's no way- there's no way you have to do this all over
again There's no way Oh, she had to talk- okay It's another
diamond Oh, okay Why is he...
Why is he doing it?
I don't understand.
Guys, it's not just me.
I told you, it's not just me.
Why is he doing all of this again?
Okay.
Why is this plan?
No, I got that ending.
I got that.
That one was easy.
Okay, he was doing that ending again.
And then, oh, so she can break the clock.
Okay, now she can break the clock.
All right.
Okay, now we're here.
Okay, this one, we don't know.
This is the ending we don't know.
Oh my god.
Y'all get out of the desert?
We don't know how.
Guys, we're never getting out of the...
This isn't the true ending yet.
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
The thing is, I don't think we're gonna be getting out of
the fucking...
We're not gonna be getting out, guys.
We're not gonna be getting out of the desert.
That was our biggest hurdle.
And I do not think it was ever gonna work.
This is never gonna work, yeah.
Don't you come on?
All right.
Okay.
I don't know what the plan is.
What the fuck is the plan?
Oh, hey, what the fuck?
Who's this guy?
I guess that's like who we're...
there's still there's still an hour okay there's no way
there's still an hour left i am at 2x speed what
the this is with cuts this is with him cutting the game he's
like editing this video and the there's two can you even
kill him okay
oh my god stab the heart I don't fucking know oh my god how
is he completing this I'm just gonna start skipping I'm so
close to start skipping oh my god I didn't have to redo this
we're gonna find oh my god how many times has he redone this
how many How many times has he redone this?
This isn't...
Oh, I swear to God.
Okay, now he has to kill the hat.
Okay.
Oh, that's smart.
That's smart.
He just got to stab the thumb.
Alright.
Alright, the speed boost.
All right.
Okay, he did it.
He did it.
Okay.
Now where are we?
Oh, shit.
She's fucked up.
What does she have to do now?
Oh, my God.
This is two times speed.
This is 2x speed.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
yeah, that's been so much longer.
Oh, the grand finale?
Oh, hey, look, there's everybody.
My fans?
Our fans.
I'll put this here so we can read the text.
Oh, that's the cat.
Oh, that's the people who are watching outside.
That's not even true ending.
That's...
Wait, it's not even there.
We're not even...
They're still stuck.
Oh my god, we went up there.
They're still...
Oh my god, and she's back.
In the desert!
Oh, my!
In the desert again.
The end is not the end.
Not the end.
Children yearn for the sand.
This could have been us, Doki.
We could have experienced this thing.
No.
No, it's almost at the five hour mark, guys.
Now who is this?
What the fuck was that guy?
Oh my god.
What the fuck was...
Okay.
Alright, he did this.
And now...
Well, he got the sun area.
Oh, she was the person in the yard.
Oh, that was her.
All right.
And now you got the moon.
This was the moon.
Oh my god.
He's still trying to fucking open this.
Oh, I'm just close to skipping more.
Why is she here?
Oh, it's talked to her.
Okay, she's talking to her.
It's from Chemical's Curse.
Oh.
Okay, so you have to do this again?
You have to do this again.
How many loops?
Step the heart.
Now what?
Okay, she's back here.
In the TV show, lad.
At least we'll know how to see the graph, guys.
At least we don't.
Thank God.
Didn't have to see my graph.
Oh, shit.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, no.
And then it loops again.
Oh.
Does it end?
Did she break the loop?
She broke the loop.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
Is that the true ending?
That we finally found true.
ending?
Is this it?
Oh, there's still more.
Oh, there's... Where are they now?
There's actually still more.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, there it is.
There's the credits.
Okay.
Okay, what happens after that?
But wait, there's more!
Yeah, what's going on?
Oh, it's Tavi's curse now.
Now we're in...
Now it's House 3.
Oh, I'm so tired, Tavi.
Now we're in House 3.
Oh, my God.
We went straight to the...
To the 3 club.
Okay.
It never ends.
We're gonna trap you in another loop.
It's called house two because there are two houses.
Oh my god.
There was a second house all along.
Hey, you already had food.
Hey.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh, he was like, it's beautiful.
Oh, my God.
Remember when we were like, it's a game within a game where
we're going to have to play Tabby's curse later?
Like, oh my God.
And then he plays Tabby's curse.
What is Mother Goppa?
Wait, he has more channels than me.
Oh.
Wait, play Tabby's Curse.
That's not Tabby's Curse.
Yeah, where's Tabby's Curse?
I was promised Tabby's Curse.
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, he has so many games.
That's true, I would have done the same thing.
Not gonna lie.
I would have done...
Bouncing on that.
Story.
Oh my god, it's Friday night Funken!
But we frogs!
Oh my god, I'm...
Ratmorph?
What's Ratmorph?
Oh my god, you're just trying to grab...
Oh my god, you're just trying to grab food.
I guess you don't...
You have to make sure you don't grab the...
Oh my god, how How long has he been playing Ratmorph for?
How long has he been playing Ratmorph?
Is the Ratmorph?
Holy shit, he morphed!
Oh my, okay, there you go, Tabby's curse.
The next hour is just Ratmorphed, Toky.
Oh my god, you're back in Tabby's curse.
Oh my god.
What is he trying to do?
Okay.
Alright, okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
Okay, he figured it out.
I don't know what he figured out, but he cut that because
apparently...
Okay.
An apple starts forming.
He had to cut it.
So that means there was something he had to get it.
This is new.
Oh, it took so long.
My food is almost here now.
You stab her?
Oh, okay.
You don't stab her.
My food.
I've been watching this for so long.
My food is here.
Okay, that's new.
Oh, does he lose?
He dies there, doesn't he?
This is a death scene, isn't it?
Oh, it's not.
It's not.
Okay, thank God.
Doki, you were going to try this?
Oh, my God.
And I assume if you died it.
He has his HP.
It's another.
dead safe
i don't what oh okay okay oh i would this have taken oh he
cuts that he cuts it
what does he do with the flower nothing
oh my god what the fuck what the fuck era is she is Oh,
where is he?
How many pictures are there?
How much
did this man suffer to get this far?
Oh, my God, he's trying to fight.
Oh, my God.
How long has he been stuck here?
How long?
I'm just scrolling through it.
It's the second desert.
Where is this?
What?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, this is the boss zone.
What?
the fuck
all right all right this is where we see him kill it okay
okay we see him kill the boss
okay he did it that what does he do is this true ending now
oh he starts throwing up is it because that's her oh that's
her because he's wearing the same shirt
house one was a lot simpler it was was that it
ending was that it was that true ending is is this true
ending oh
that was the true ending that was oh my god that was the
true ending oh and that was i think that was it i think that
was it
It's free That's me it That's it That's it Okay I will say
That I will say That That ending was a bit anticlimactic
That that's That was That was a little anticlimactic Yeah
For the last ending I...
Oh, it was an extra ending.
He missed.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, it wasn't...
Okay, the true ending was when the girl shot, like, keep me
close shot.
I'm okay.
Okay, at least...
All right, if that was the true ending, then that was a...
The fact that it led into a house three was funny.
Oh my God.
We were never done that.
Two shout again to Madly Badass Hero.
I'm sorry, I had to york your video for a little bit.
I had to know.
We all had to know how this goes.
Like, we all needed to know when it ends.
Shout out to Matt for...
Well, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know that I did it, but...
Shout out to his video for...
That we can see how it ends.
Oh, my God.
That was crazy.
That was a crazy game.
I don't think... I didn't get the true ending in the
original house.
but i remember it was a lot easier to do compared the house
to i would have not made it out of the desert for sure i
would have i i think i would have the fact that you had to
do so many steps i thought like the desert was it as long as
you get through the desert you'll get there but apparently
not guys apparently we found out that there was more than
just the desert was not even part of the true ending it
wasn't even it wasn't even part it was like a step towards
the true ending.
It was like the halfway point.
There was no, we weren't, I didn't think this was going to
be a long stream either.
I thought we would, I thought this was like my one-off
stream today.
I thought this was my one-off two-hour stream, like, around
the two-hour stream, but I guess I was wrong.
I guess I was fucking wrong.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
I hope you guys enjoyed the stream today.
It's sushi time for me.
It's time to relax.
and rest up.
I hope you enjoy the journey.
It's a fun game.
I think it was just the desert.
I will say I liked the game until the desert part.
I think if we stopped, if we stopped at the point where
there was no, where we didn't do the desert, I would have
been fine.
I enjoyed it up to the desert.
But I still think it was a really good sequel to the
original house game um had a great time uh streaming this
game for you guys okay i'm having a great time watching it
as always everybody stay hydrated pause check get up and
move around get that blood flowing enemy stay up for me head
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody go rest up guys bye everyone bye